Alright guys, welcome to this Python game
development video series. And we will be
using the famous pi game library of Python to
create this school space in reader game. And
we are going to go really in depth into the spy
game and learn about a lot of different concepts.
And specifically, we will be learning a
lot about like new parts of Python that
you haven't explored yet. And new parts of pi
game, like moving characters, shooting bullets,
understanding game concepts like game loops and
stuff like that. So if you haven't ever created
a game, or you have only created a very basic
game, this would be a very good starting point
for you guys. So before we get started on all of
that cool stuff, learning about game development
and stuff like that, you should make sure that the
basic stuff is installed. So first basic stuff is
obviously Python. So if Python is not installed,
if you're using Python for the first time,
just go to python.org. And then click on downloads
and just download the latest version of Python.
After downloading Python, we are going to be using
ID which is basically a cooler way to write code
of Python. So I'm going to be using pi charm. And
if you don't want to buy the professional version,
although you have a 30 day trial, which you can
use for this course. But if you don't want to buy
it, just download the community version, which is
free, and you won't need more than the community
version. But if you're using something like
Sublime Text, or maybe the main Python terminal,
that's also fine, it won't matter. But if you want
to follow along completely, make sure that you
download pi charm. And thirdly, you can just have
a look at the PI game website that we are going
to be using to create our game. So you can just
have a look at it, it's not really necessary. But
you can just have a look at what has been done
with this PI game and look at the Games maybe
and you know, just kind of get ideas. So let's
get started. Make sure that you have downloaded
Python, after you have downloaded pi jam, it
will look somewhat like this. Now that we have
everything installed, we need to make sure that
we have this new project over here. So for that,
just go to file, click on new project. And then
right down the project name over here, I have
already created the project and I'm calling it
Space Invaders because this is the game that we'll
be creating, and probably have already played
this game when you were a child. But the main
idea is that there is a ship at the bottom and
is going to hit the enemies that are at the top
by shooting a bullet. And every time you hit an
enemy, your point increases and the enemies slowly
come down. If it touches the spaceship, you lose.
And the final score is what how many enemies you
have shot. So that's the basic idea of the game.
But you'll understand more as we go through the
videos. So after you have created this project,
we are going to create a new file over here and
we're just going to call it main because most
of our code is going to go inside this main dot
Python file. And after that, we need to install
pi game. So if you're using terminal, you can just
open up your terminal by typing in cmd. And you
can just type in pip install pi game. And this is
for people who are not using pi charm, or you're
using something else like Sublime Text or Python
terminal. But if you're using pi charm, what you
would do is you would go to File and then you
would go to settings and in settings, you would
go to project name, the whatever name you have
given if you want to follow along called spacing
reedham. And then go to project entrepreneur. And
over there you can see I've already installed
pi game. And if this PI game is not already
installed, just go to this plus sign over here
and search for pi game by game and then you can
select it and click on Install package and this
will install pi game onto your computer. Now I've
already installed pi game, so I'm not going to
install it again. And after that you can just type
in by import pi game. And if this doesn't show
an error, that means that pi game is installed on
your computer. So this is pretty much it. This was
a pretty small video, just an introduction video,
we're going to be doing a lot of cool stuff.
From the next video, we are going to be creating
our game, we are not going to go into theory and
stuff, we're just going to start with practical
stuff and actually start creating a game. So we
are going to be creating a game window next time.
So as you can see, this pie chart has a window
right now. So we are going to be creating this
kind of a window in the next video with a cross
button over here. So I'll see you over there.
And just to recap, what we did in the last
video was installed by game and in this video,
we are going to be creating our first Python
game window using pi game. So obviously the first
thing we need to do is import pi game into our
program. And hopefully you have already created
this mean.py file, if you haven't just created
right now. And first of all, we are going to
import pi game. And then we need to initialize pi
game to access all of the code methods and all of
the other stuff that is inside this PI game
module. So to initialize this PI game module,
what we need to do is just type in pi game.in
it so whenever from now on to create a game or
create a new game. Just make sure you add this
line otherwise your Python or pi game code is
not going to work. So let me just add a little
bit of comment. We're here saying initialize the
PI game. Alright, so after initialization, we have
to create our screen. And pi game makes it really,
really easy. It's just one line of code. It's
crazy. So we just want the right screen. And
this is our variable. And we can just write pi
game. And this is to access the methods that are
inside this pygame module. And we need to access
the display dot set mode method. And then inside
these brackets, we need to add another bracket. So
this is a tuple, make sure you add another bracket
inside it, otherwise, it's not going to work.
And our people mess up over here and then ask,
why is it not working? It's because you haven't
added another bracket over here. And then inside
it is going to take in two values, the height and
the width of the window that you want to create.
So I'm just going to give it for now a value of
800 pixels of height and 600 pixels of width.
So this should be good. And let me just add a
comment, create the screen. And let me just format
this properly. So this is all you need to create
a screen. But as you will see, after we run this
program that it has won me bad thing about it. So
as you can see the game window was created. But
after a few seconds is just went away. Let me show
it to you guys again. So after we click on Play,
it stays there for like one or two seconds, then
it goes away. And this is because our Python
program goes through these three lines, and then
just exits the program. And therefore you can't
see that screen for a long time. Because it just
takes one or two seconds for this program to run.
And that's it. So one way to bypass that is just
create an infinite loop over here. And this also
has problems. But just to show you guys that it
works, I'm going to do it. And I'm going to make
sure that my task managers open because this
will hand my computer. So make sure that your
task manager is also open. Because this will Hank
the window, at least that you're working on. But
just to show you guys, I'm going to run this
and you will be able to see that the window is
there. But it is totally hand. So you can see the
window is there. But it's nothing is working over
here. And this cross button is not working. Let me
just go back over here and close my Python window,
click on end task and it has been closed. Now why
is it hanging? Why is it not just closing down by
pressing this cross button? It is because we don't
have an event of a quit function over here. So
there is no way to quit the program. Our program
is just inside this while loop and is now able
to end and Windows make sure that that program
gets high. And that's why we need to add a quick
functionality to our PI game game window. Just
like this window has on pressing this close button
this window closes. So for that we are going to
be using something known as events. Now we'll get
into events more a little bit later. But for right
now just understand that event is anything that is
happening inside your game paint. By game window,
I just mean a window inside which your game is
being played. So anything happening inside that
game window is basically an event. So for example,
if you press arrow keys or anything on your
keyboard, you move your mouse that is an event
and even when you press this close button, that
is also an event in pygame. So this pressing of
the close button is actually known as a quit
event in pygame. So we are going to make sure
that we exit this loop when this close button is
pressed. So for that, what we are going to do is
we are just going to create a variable, let's call
it running and we are going to give it a value of
true. And inside this while loop we are instead of
just typing in while true to make it an infinite
loop, let's call it while running. And whenever
we want to break outside of this infinite loop,
we're just gonna turn the variable of running
into false, and it will automatically break this
while loop. So if you don't know the basics of
Python, or programming, basically, while true runs
infinitely and when this value of true is turned
to false, it comes out of the loop. But we're not
going to go into much into that because that's
just like very basic programming. So anyways,
after writing while running, what we need to do is
go through the list of events that are happening
inside our game window. So for that, we are going
to create a for loop and create a variable event.
And then we are going to loop through all of
the events that are happening inside our game
window. How do you do that pygame makes it really
easy. Just type in PI game dot event dot get and
then brackets and this makes sure that all of
the events that are there that are happening,
get into this pygame dot event dot gate. And then
we can loop all of these events using the for loop
and one by one check. If this cross button has
been pressed, and women whenever this cross button
is being pressed, we'll just turn this while loop
into false so this is pretty easy. So inside this
for event we're gonna check if the close button
has been pressed. And how do you do that just type
in if event dot type equals equals two, and then
we are going to check whether the event in PI game
is quit or not. If it's great, then we're going
to change the value of running into false. So
this is pretty easy. So we have changed the value
of true into false whenever the close button is
being pressed. And this close button is basically
a quit event. And we are going to loop through
all of the events to find this create event. So
we're going to go into more into events a little
bit later. But for right now, just understand this
is what we are doing. So let's just play this and
understand whether it's working or not. Let's see.
So right now you can see that we do system is not
initialized, it's giving us an error. It says pi
game dot event dot gate. Alright, so the problem
is that we have misspelled This is not pygame dot
small letter squared is just pi game dot quit. And
that's pretty much it. So when you are dealing
with a lot of syntax, you have to make sure that
you write the correct one but small problem, we
are going to click on play. And now you can see
that this is working and our window is not going
anywhere the computer is not hanging, it's looking
pretty good. Alright guys, let me just go through
this once more what we are doing over here. So we
have created our screen, we have initialized our
PI game. And then over here we have created a game
loop. So let's actually call it the game loop
over here, we're just going to add a comment
that says game loop. So this is an infinite loop,
which makes sure that the game is running always,
and the window doesn't close down. And we know we
want to do something like move a bullet or move
a play or something like that move a human being
inside a game window, we have to make sure that we
do stuff inside this while infinite loop which
only exists when this close button is pressed.
And we have implemented that close functionality
over here by pressing by getting the events all
of the events using this PI game dot event dot get
method. And then we are looping through all of the
events. So if more events are added, for example,
if somebody presses an arrow key to move forward,
that is also going to be looped in does pygame
dot event dot loop. And then we can add another
condition that if arrow key is pressed move
that player but more of that in the future.
For right now just understand, we looked at event
dot type equals two pi game dot quit and then we
change the running into false to make sure that
we come out of this while loop. And I know guys,
I'm revealing a lot of stuff right now. But this
is like the basics of game development. So I want
to make sure that you guys understand it properly.
Anyways guys, this is pretty much it for this
video. In the next video, we are going to change
the title and add some stuff into our game window.
So I'll really look forward to that. So right
now it's just blank. And it's just saying my game
window is not cool. So we're going to look into
that in the next video. I'll see you over there.
So in the last video, we learn how to create this
game window using pi game. So this window is a
little bit not personalized, because it says pi
game window over here. The background is weird,
the logo is not there. So in this video, we are
going to be learning about three main things.
So first thing is how to change the caption
of this window instead of pygame window will
make it something say something like Space
Invaders, we're going to learn how to change
the logo of this window right now is like
a snake or a turtle or something like that,
and how to change the background color of this
window. Now these three things are very basic,
but obviously very important when you're creating
a game. So let's get started on that. And first
thing we're going to do is obviously just comment
that so that you guys can come back to this code
and look what's happening. So we're going to
write a comment title and icon and after that,
we are going to change the caption or the title
of our window and pygame makes it very, very easy,
you just write it by game dot display. Because
we are meddling with the display of our windows
we have to write in on display, and then dot
set underscore caption and there it requires
the title of the window let's just call it
Space Invaders because that is what we are
creating. And then we are going to create the
image so you must have been seeing this UFO dot
png image over here we are going to be using this
image in just a second I'm going to show you how
you can get this image but before that, let me
just add this icon inside our program. So for
that this is also very easy. First of all, what
you can do if you want to get the same image is
that you can go to this website known as flat
icon.com and then search for spaceships or any
kind of icon so I've searched for spaceship and
I got this cute UFO icon. So to download this,
you can just click on Download collection and
make sure that you select PNG and then 32 by
32 pixels size. So whenever you're working
with an icon and pygame make sure you select
the 32 into 32. I haven't experimented with 24
or 16 pixels. It might work but I'm just going
to go with 32 into 32 pixels. You can select
any other icon if you want. So I selected this
icon and I just downloaded it into my project and
here is UFO dot png. Now to add this inside our
Python program it's pretty easy Just type in icon
equals two pi game dot image because we are using
an image, so we are going to be using the image
module that is inside pi game. And then dot load,
we want the image to load. And then we just
write the name of the image. So in my case,
it's UFO dot png. So we are going to use that UFO
dot png. And then the next line is pretty simple,
we are going to use the same dot display that
we did with the title. And we're just going to
write that over here. And then just said, snort
showing by this, I think it's set underscore
icon. So you can use that. And then you just
type in the variable name of icon over here,
that we have created. And this will make sure
that the icon has been added. So let's just run
this and see if it's working or not. So as you
can see, the icon is also working and the Space
Invaders is there. So this is looking pretty good,
we have learned how to add an image, not exactly
an image just icon over here and change the title
of our window. So this is looking pretty good. The
third thing we need to learn is how to change the
look or the background of our window. So for that,
we need to use something known as screen dot fill.
So we are going to go inside our while running
loop and over here we are going to write screen.
So anything that you want to be persistent inside
our game window that you want to make sure that
appears continuously, it can be an image or it
can be some text, it has to go inside this running
infinite while loop. That is where we are going to
change the color inside this running infinite
while loop. So we're going to just state screen
dot fill. And then inside this, we're going to
create a tuple make sure you add another bracket
inside it. So there are two brackets, and then
you give it three values of RGB. So we're going to
give it I'm going to explain what RGB is in just
a second, I'm just gonna give it a value of 000.
Right now, just to understand this RGB means is
red, green, and blue. And basically every color in
this world is made up of these three values. And
one more, you can see a PCT, but let's not go into
that. So RGB basically stands for red, green, and
blue. And this is the values these are the three
values that you can use to basically implement any
color on the screen. So this makes sure and this
value goes from zero to 255. So you can make it
255. But not more than that. And you can use it in
a combination. So they say we want just a pure red
color. So we'll say red, we want to 55 and then
green zero and blue zero. And similarly, if you
just want a green color, we can say zero to 55,
and blue as zero now what if we wanted a light,
light green color, we can lower down this value
to maybe like 150. So this will be a lighter
version of pure green. So this is how it works,
basically. And just to show you guys a more better
version of RGB, or what you can do with RGB. If
you haven't understood it properly, let's go to
Google. And you can just type in color to RGB
and go to any website. But I'm just going to go to
this reputable website. And over here you can see
these RGB values. So obviously, I told you red
is 255 00 line is 255 03, this, and similarly,
and so on. So let's go with this red color
right now. And you can choose any values. And
there are a lot more colors, you can even make
your own colors by trying out different three
values. So just experiment with it a little bit.
So I'm going to just choose the red color. So we
are going to go back to our code and I'm going
to write down to 55. But this is not going to
work even though we have tried, but this is not
gonna work just telling you in advance. So you
can see that it's not working, it's just a black
screen. So over here, we need to use something
known as update. So right now our display is not
updating. So that's why pygame provides a method
known as display update to make sure that if we
add anything inside our display window, it gets
updated inside this while running loop. So we for
that is pretty easy, just make sure that you add
it after every game. So it's pi game dot display.
So let's just try display dot update. And that's
it. So we have to add a couple of lines inside
your pipe icon game code. The first line is this
init line. And obviously you need to make a screen
but two lines that are always going to be there is
this init line. And the second line that's always
going to be there is this update line because you
want to update your screen because your players is
going to move away the bullets are going to moving
to Amy's going to move moving the score is going
to be changing. So you want to make sure that your
display is always updating and by display I just
mean the game window that we are working on. For
this program. It means this screen variable. So
anyways, so now we have updated it. Let's give
it a shot. Let's click on Play and as you can see
now it's in red color. So it looks good. We have
changed the title. We have changed the logo and
our screen is updating to read, I don't like it,
I just wanted to show you guys that you can change
the color and maybe we'll change it to something
a little bit more funky in the later videos right
now I'm just going to go with black that is 000.
And that's pretty much it. So guys, I'll see
you in the next video where we are going to be
finally adding images and our player that is maybe
a spaceship some kind inside our game window. And
so I'll see you there where we are going to learn
how to add images inside our game. So peace out.
So in the last video, we learned how to add
a caption and a logo and how to change the
background screen of our game window. In this
video, we are going to learn how to add an
image to our game window, which is pretty cool and
pretty easy because of pygame. But first of all,
let's look at the player PNG which we are
going to add inside our game window which
is kind of a spaceship which is shooting being
sort of its arms. So if you want this image,
you can just go to flat icon.com and download
this image. Obviously you can use any other image
you want. But I'm just going to stick with this
image. And you can go to download collection. And
obviously search for arcade space over here.
If you want this exact image and then choose
PNG and choose a 64 by 64 pixel. Obviously, you
can resize it in pygame. But I've seen that it's
better if you already get the image of the size
that you want. In this case, I want a 60 by 64 by
64 pixel version. So I'm going to take that, and
I've already added it to my project over here.
So after you have done that over here, then you
can come back and we can start adding the image.
But before we even start that, I just want to
discuss what is this 806 100 I have put over here,
I wanted to discuss this because this 800 is the
width and the 600 is the height, I think I might
have said something wrong about this. In the
starting videos. This 800 is actually the width
and not the height and the 600 is the height. So
if you look at our window, this is the x axis,
you can think of this window as an x and y axis
window. So if we go from left to right, this is
an X axis. And if you could go from top to bottom,
this is a Y axis. So it's always starts from zero
comma zero, which is at the top left corner,
and then we as we go on the right hand side,
the x value starts to increase. And on this top
right corner, the x value is 800. Because that
stands for width. And now if we go from top to
bottom, the value of y increases while the x
value remains the same. So over here, the value
is 600. But the value of x is zero. So if you
don't understand it a lot, don't worry about it.
Just think of it as this left, left to right is
basically x. and the value right now of this whole
window is 800 in terms of its width, and the value
from top to bottom is 600. And the value at the
bottom is 600. And if you want to go into into the
middle, it's approximately 300. Not approximately
exactly it's 300. So why I'm telling you this,
because we want to place our image in a particular
position. So that's why we need to give it in stat
coordinates. Obviously, you can experiment with
coordinates a little bit, but we'll go into it.
So let me just add a comment over here so that we
know that we are talking about the player and then
we need to add the player image which is pretty
easy like we have done it in the in terms of the
logo. So let's just copy and paste this over here
and change the UFO to player dot png. And then we
are going to give it the x and y axis. Where do
you want the image to be positioned. So let's
create two more variables. Let's call this player
x. And we're going to give it the value of 370.
And I'm going to go into why we give these values
to player x and player y. So these variables
basically represents the coordinates that we want.
And over this, we are going to give the buyer the
value of 480. So why have we done that. So if we
look at this window, we want to clear image to
appear somewhere over here, which is exactly the
half of the screen width. So we want it to appear
at the starting of the game, at least we want
it to appear in the middle. And we want it to
appear in the lower half of this window. So the y
axis should be closer to 600. Because this point
is 600. If you guys remember this lower part, so
you want it to appear a little bit above it. So we
can give it a value of about 480 or 450, whatever
you guys want. And then the x value we're giving
it 370 which is a little bit half less than half
of the width. So the width is 800. And if we go
a little bit less than this, this is 370. Because
we have to consider the size of the image itself.
If we give it exactly the value of 400 then it's
not going to fit perfectly. That's why we have
given these values so you can see that the 370 is
somewhat half of 800 and this purity is close to
600. Obviously when we change the values, you will
understand this concept a little bit better and
feel free to change this values and see the effect
it has. Now after this, we're just going to create
a function and we are going to call it player.
Now I'm going to go into why we are creating a
function. But let's just create a function for
now. And then we're going to use a method known
as screen dot blit. So grid basically means to
draw, so we are drawing an image of player on to
our screen. And this screen is actually known as
the surface of our game, we'll go into what it is
surface, which later I know I'm saying that
a lot, but it's not relevant to this video,
but just understand that we are drawing this image
of player dot png on our game window, by using
this method known as dot blade. And dot blade
blade actually means to draw. So we after loading
the image, you also need to draw it on the screen.
So that's why we are using this screen dot blade
method. And over here, it requires two parameters
or values. The first value is of the image itself.
So we are going to give it the image. And the
second thing it requires are the coordinates.
So we are going to give it the coordinates of
player x and player y. So the x and y coordinates.
After this, we are going to call it I'm just
going to ask you guys a question, Where do you
think we should call this player, we want this
player to appear in every frame of the screen,
we don't ever want this player to disappear.
If you guys said inside this while loop,
you guys are correct. So we are going to call this
player method inside over here. So let's just call
it and we're going to just call it over here, like
this, and make sure that display method is called
after this screen dot fill method. Otherwise,
this player won't appear on the screen. Why do you
think that is, this is because the screen is drawn
first. And then on top of the screen, we draw a
player or a spaceship. If the opposite was true,
then the spaceship will be drawn underneath the
skin, the screen, not the skin, but then it will
be drawn underneath the screen. So that is why we
always want it to be drawn after screen dot fill.
Actually, let's change let's remove this position
to from there to over here somewhere. So that we
guys know where this so because we are going to
be adding a lot of images and stuff. That's why
we need to make sure that this screen dot fill is
just above everything, and all the other things
and drawn on top of the screen. Alright guys,
so this is pretty much it. Let me just add another
comment, I don't know where it disappeared, the
standard for RGB, and red, green, blue, just to
make sure that you guys still remember what this
is. Alright, so this is looking pretty good. And
our player should appear on the screen. So let's
run it. And then we'll just go through all of this
stuff again to see what is happening. Alright,
so as you can see, our image has appeared on the
screen. So first, we loaded the image in display
an image variable, we pointed out the x and y
values and the x and y values were dependent
on the screen size that we gave over here. 806
100 because he wanted it to appear in the let
me just close this one, the old one. All right.
And because he wanted it to appear in the middle,
that is why we gave it the value of approximately
half of the screen. For example, if I gave it the
value of let's say just to experiment, let's say
we gave it the value of let's say 750 that is
close to right hand side, and we reloaded it.
And let's wait for it. Okay, as you can see,
it appeared on the right hand side. So you can
see that the x value has increased. And similarly
if we decrease it to, let's say about 30. I'm
just showing you this to guys so that you guys
can understand the x and y positions clearly,
you can see that it appears on the left hand
side. So let's change it to back to about 370.
And similarly in y if we change this to maybe
30 you will see that it appears on the top of the
screen instead of at the bottom of the screen. So
as we get go down, we are getting closer to that
600 value. So we are going to from zero to 600.
So let's get back to 480. And hopefully now you
guys have understood properly the meaning of this
x and y axes. So anyways, after that we created
this function known as player and inscribed
that we drew this image onto the screen and
it required two values the image the x and
y coordinates and then to make sure that this
player is always shown on the screen we added
it to this wild game loop infinite loop. So guys,
this is pretty much it for this video. I might be
repeating a lot of things a lot of times that
might be a little bit irritating for some guys,
but hopefully you guys understood it properly.
In the next video we are going to learn how to
move this player from left hand side to right
hand side using our arrow keys on a keyboard.
That's going to be really exciting. Let's wait
for that. So as in the next video, peace out
In the last video, we learned how to add an image
inside our game window. In this video, we are
going to learn how to move this image left, right
or top or bottom. So basically we are concerned
about the movement of an object inside our game
window. Or anything that we draw it can be image,
it can be an text after you watch the 3d game
and understand how the mechanics of movement
in a game works. So just to make sure that you
guys understand it, I have created an image so
that you guys can understand what we are going
to do, and the basics of movement of an image
or anything that you want. So obviously, we have
created a game window. This is argument though it
is 800 wide, that is 800x axis, and then it's
600 is height. That is you can see it on this
as y axis. And our spaceship currently is at
370 pixels. As we have added this over here,
that is the player x s ad 370 pixels. Now if we go
back to our image, what if we wanted this image to
move from over here to over here, we can just add
five pixels to our already existing 370 pixels and
this image will move in the right hand direction.
And now what if we added five pixel continuously,
so this five pixel will be added continuously,
this image will continue to move towards the
right hand side. So for example, we can add
a functionality which adds five pixels to our
existing 370 pixels in a while loop, some kind of
a while loop. And this will happen continuously
after every iteration of our loop. Similarly,
if we want to move it to the left hand side,
we can just decrease some value from our 370
pixel value. That is we can decrease some x
player x value and we will move towards the left
hand side. And similarly if we want to move up,
we can subtract some y values. So currently, the y
value of this is 480. So if we subtract some value
from this 480, it will move towards up direction
and if we add some value, it will move in the
downward direction. So adding and subtracting
values from x and y coordinates have a current
position of the object or in this case, patient
can lead to a movement of that object. And we have
to add it to a while loop because we want it to
happen continuously. So if we go back to our code,
we need to add one thing before I can show
you guys how we can add values to our player
x and player by or we how we can subtract it. So
before that we need to make some changes, because
currently there is no way to manipulate the x and
y coordinates from our while running loop. And if
you didn't understand what I meant by this over
here, don't worry about it. When we actually write
the code, you'll understand what is happening and
what I mean by increasing the x value to move it
towards the right hand direction. Basically, if
you move it very, very quickly, it won't seem that
the image is moving, it will just seem like that
the spaceship is continuously moving. Because of
the effect of persistence. In our eyes, we can't
see things that are happening very, very quickly.
Like magicians do, they create illusions by moving
things really really quickly. And the persistence
in it tells us that the image hasn't been erased
and then created over here, it just assumes that
the image has moved on the right hand direction
if you're adding the five value to our already
existing x coordinate. So anyways, we need to do
something so that we can manipulate the value of
player x and player y from the running y Lu. So
what we can do is go to this def player function
and over here at x comma y, so that we can send
in the values of the new x&y coordinates that we
want. And then instead of player x and player
y, we can just add x and y. So that the values
that we send to this player instead of the last
value is that it caught from player x and player
y. Instead of that the new values that we send in
of x and y are being shown on the screen are being
drawn on the screen. So now we have to go back to
the place where we are calling this function. So
over here, right now let's just write in player
x and player y. And you will see that there has
been no change. So let me just exit this first and
then play it again. Let's play it. So you will see
that there has been no change because you're not
manipulating the player x and player y value right
now. So let's go through this once as to what's
happening over here. So first, it goes to this
code, it creates the spaceship, then it takes the
coordinates of the x and y of your player or the
spaceship, and then there is this player exchange.
Let me remove this right now we don't need it. And
then if we go down, we have created this function
of death player x comma y. And then this is being
drawn on the screen. So this code hasn't been
executed yet because it is inside this wandering
while running loop. But the program just sees
that this exists. Now when we go down over here,
then this player thing is called and it takes the
player x and player y value from here and sends
it to this Deaf player function and it Inside
x and y, currently the 370 and 480 exists. So
this image is being drawn at this coordinate.
Now what if we change the value inside a while
running function. So for example, let's say we
increase the value of player x by something small,
this let's, let's increase continuously by five.
So this will move really, really quickly, and you
won't be able to see the image moving towards the
right hand side. But I just want to show it to you
guys for the speed. So you can see how quickly it
moved, I hope you call it, this will slow it down,
I'm just going to give it the value of 0.1. so
that you guys can see it properly. And you will
see that it is moving in the right hand side
direction slowly. So why is this happening.
So every time this while loop is running, the
player x coordinate increases by 0.1. And this
value is sent over here and this function player
function, and then it is sent to this new player
function. And a new image is basically drawn on
a new coordinate and the original image is being
removed. So for example, let's also just, let's
make it 0.2. And this time, we are also going to
print out the value of player x so that you guys
can see that the player x value is increasing from
our original value. So here, you can see it being
increased by 0.1. And it's going on, let's stop it
right now. And let's actually try it to move it in
the left hand left hand side direction, so let's
give it a minus value of 0.1. So now we want to
decrease the value. So instead of increasing the
value, we want to decrease the value and move it
towards the left hand side. So let's play it again
this time, and hopefully, let's just remove the
player of the print function because we don't need
it. So now let's play it. And you can see it's
moving towards the left hand side. And similarly,
if we do instead of the x coordinate, we do the y
coordinate and decrease its value is going to go
towards the up direction. So let's reload it.
And you will be able to see that it's moving
towards the up direction. And similarly if we
add stock, it is going to go down. So hopefully
you guys understood the mechanics of a movement of
an object. Just to reiterate, why is this movement
happening? Why is when when we are decreasing, the
value in y is going up. So because at the bottom,
the value of y coordinate is 600. So if we
decrease the value, it is going up. So over here,
it's about 480. And if we decrease it more, it's
going to go towards up direction. And similarly
if we increase it, it's gonna go below more
than 600 coordinates. So right now you can see
there are some, some fallacies with this system.
Right now, we can't control where this is going,
and you will be able to see that it just goes
outside the screen. So we need to do a couple
of things. First, we need to make sure that we can
control the movement of the spaceship in the left
and the right hand direction using an arrow keys
on the keyboard. And the second thing we need to
do is add a boundary so that the spaceship
doesn't go beyond our game window right now
is just disappearing by going outside the game
window. So we'll be handling these two things
in the next and the coming videos. In the next
video, we are going to learn how to add keyboard
support to our game. So basically, we are going to
control our spaceship using arrow keys. And that's
going to be really exciting. So I'll see you in
the next video. This is pretty much it for this.
And the last video we learned about the movement
mechanics of the objects in our game window. So
for example, if you do player y equals two
minus equals to 0.1, then it will move in
the other direction. So if I run this man, you
can see that our spacious is moving in upward
direction. But right now we don't have any way to
control the spaceship, we can't control it using
our keyboard. And this is exactly what we will be
learning in this video. So what we'll be doing is
that when we press a left arrow key on a keyboard,
the spaceship is going to move towards the left
hand side. And when we press the right hand side
arrow key, then a spaceship is going to move on
the right hand side. So what is the algorithm
to do that? So first of all, we are going to
check whether any each stroke is being pressed
on our keyboard, and after we check that we are
going to check whether the keystroke pressed is
either left hand side arrow key or the right hand
side arrow key. So we are going to do that. So
let me just write down an if condition. Let me
just remove this over here, we don't need it. So
after that, let me just tell you one more thing.
So any keystroke that is pressed on a keyboard is
actually an event. And as we have discussed before
that an event is anything that is happening inside
our game window, any kind of input control. So for
example, if we move a mouse, we click somewhere
we close this is Windows. So this is a quit event.
And similarly when we whenever we press any key
stroke on our keyboard, it is a key stroke event.
So for example, every event gets logged inside
this pygame dot event dot get and we loop through
all the events that are being stored inside it.
And then after every iteration. So for example,
let's say in the first iteration of this while
loop, a keystroke is not being placed but on the
10th iteration. A keystroke is being pressed and
it will get stored inside of spy game dot event
dot get And we'll be able to loop through that.
And check whether a keystroke has been pressed
or not. So, inside this, I'm just going to write
an if condition, which says actually before that,
let me just add a comment so that you guys
understand what we are doing. I'm going to write
if key stroke, the stroke is pressed, check,
whether is right, or left. So this is basically
what we'll be doing. Not keystroke or keystroke.
Oh, god, I'm gonna mess up my spelling. Alright,
keystroke. Can't get this feeling right. All
right. So anyways, how do you check whether
keystroke is being pressed or not by gay makes
it really, really easy. It's kind of an event,
which is pygame dot key down. So this basically
check if any keystroke it doesn't have to be left
or the right it can be alphabet, a even backspace
or space, it basically checks if any keystroke is
being pressed. So first, we are going to do
that we are going to write if event dot type,
which we did inside this if condition. So we
have to go actually inside this for loop. So
we'll just press this tab button over here. Let's
press this. So now we are inside this event for
loop. And now we are looping through all the
events that are there. And if the event dot
type is equals equals to pi game dot key key down,
then this means that a keystroke has been pressed
on a computer. And now we have to check whether
the keystroke that was pressed is left. Alright,
so this is also pretty easy. We just again
type event dot this time we type in dot key
because we want to find out the key that is being
pressed. And we just type in PI game dot key left,
key left. And this will just check whether the key
that has been praised is the left arrow or not.
If that is the left arrow, it says for right now
print. left arrow is pressed. And after that I'm
going to write again, I'm just going to copy and
paste this over here. Like this, and over here,
I'm just going to write right. And instead of
K underscore left, I'm going to add the right.
Alright, so basically what this does is it checks
with any keystroke is pressed and then it checks
whether the keystroke that is being pressed,
is left or right. And after that we are going
to check when the keystroke is being released.
So after pressing down on the left arrow key,
when we remove our finger from that left arrow
key, that is known as the removal of the keystroke
or the key up. So key down is pressing that key
or pressing any button on the keyboard and key up
is basically releasing that press. So we're going
to check for that over here if event dot type is
equals equals to pi game dot key up. So hopefully
we'll be able to find that key up over here. And
then over here, we're just going to check if
it was the left key or the right arrow key,
and then we are going to print something so
that is pretty simple. We can just copy this
from here. Let's copy this, paste this and we are
going to give a condition that if the left or the
right arrow key was pressed, so we can just copy
this from here and put this colon mark. And then
over here, we're just gonna write key keystroke
has been released this series so you guys know
what is going on. And I want you to write this
code down and then actually try it out yourself
so that you guys know what's happening behind the
scenes. So now we can just press on Play and over
here is going to do nothing. But on our print
screen over here we are printing all of these
things. So let's press the left arrow key and see
if something happens. So we have to first activate
our window over here, and then we can press the
left arrow key and we can see that the left arrow
is pressed. And when I remove my finger, it says
keystroke has been released. Now what if I keep
pressing on a left arrow key if I keep pressing,
it will just say left arrow is pressed and the
keystroke has been released. And similarly if I
press the right arrow key, it says right arrow is
pressed. But if I press any other key, it prints
nothing. So let's actually create a statement
over here to let's say, a keystroke is pressed
so that we know when any other key is pressed,
it also runs. So over here, we can just press the
left arrow key again, as you can see, a keystroke
is pressed left arrow key is pressed and keystroke
has been released. But if you press something
else, let's say enter, it just says a keystroke
is pressed and not the left and the right arrow
key. And that means that our keyboard strokes are
working. So now we can just minimize it and we're
going to create a new variable over here. And this
will signify the change that we want an x so if we
want the X to move in right hand direction,
we need to add value to this 370 existing
value and we wanted to move on the left hand side
direction we need to decrease value from eight. So
I'm going to just call it over here create a new
variable And call it player x underscore change
equals two and right now I'm going to give it a
value of zero. And inside our if conditions when
the left key is pressed, I want it to increase
by 0.1. And when sorry, decreased by 0.1, and
we're gonna change this 0.1 number, it basically
signifies the speed with which you want the object
to move. And in this case, it's spaceship,
how quickly you want the spaceship to move,
and we are going to change it later. And even in
this video, we will see how it goes if it moves
too slowly or too fast. But anyways, right, now we
are going to decrease the value when the left key
is pressed and increase the value when the right
key is pressed. So what kind of change Do we want
in our x, when we want the left arrow keys press,
so we're going to just right over here, player x,
and it's called change, and we want to decrease
the value by 0.1, let's say and when the right
arrow key is pressed, we want to increase this
change by 0.1. So let's remove this minus value
from over here. And when the key is released,
we want the spaceship to stop moving. And that
is why we want the change to be zero when our
keystroke is released. So over here, we are just
going to paste this over here. So this is looking
pretty good. Let's actually remove this comment
from here. And then we can just add this player
exchange to our existing player x x coordinate,
so I'm just going to write here x plus equals
two, and then player exchange. So doesn't matter
whether we are adding over here because we have
given a term value of minus 0.1. And over here
we are given it a positive value. So whenever
something is added, and the value is negative,
so I'm just going to give you an example. Alright,
so that you guys can understand this arithmetic
properly. You might be thinking that why are we
adding over here because we want to subtract 0.1,
right, so let's say our current value is
370. Let's actually take a smaller value,
let's take our player x coordinate is five. And
then when we do plus equal to So this basically
means equals to five plus, and then the value that
is player x underscore change. So right now this
value is minus 0.1. If the key left is activated,
so this value will we actually minus 0.1. So after
this arithmetic is processed, this will turn
actually into, so let me just add arrow key,
this will actually turn into five equals to
five, minus 0.1. And similarly, if we add,
then the addition is pretty, pretty obvious. So
we can just add 0.1. And this will remain the
same just 0.1. And the value will be 5.1. So this
is how this operator over here works. So we don't
need to worry about whether we are subtracting or
adding if we have added our arithmetic operator
over here, in this case, it smiles. So this should
be working, let's run our main.py file and see if
it is working. So let's activate it. And over
here, when you press a left arrow key, our ship
is moving. And when we press the right arrow
key, our ship is moving and we when we release
the keystroke, it is still moving. Why is that the
case. So let's go over here and see. All right,
so here the place x underscore change is 0.1.
So we have to change it to value zero, because
we don't want it to move, you can actually change
it to 0.1 to see how it works, how the spaceship
is stopping. So let's try it again. Now when we
move on the right hand direction, and we release,
the keystroke, the ship actually stops. So
this is looking pretty good. But Asli, this,
the speed is a little bit slow. So I'm going to
increase the value to 0.3. And now if we run it,
our speed should be sufficiently well. So this is
looking pretty good in future will change 0.3 to
a higher value when we use the clock concept. But
we are not using it right now. So this is looking
pretty good as patient is moving perfectly. And
just to recap, what we did in this video was first
we checked whether any keystroke has been pressed
on the keyboard. And then if the left keystroke is
pressed, then we increase or decrease the value
of player exchanged by 0.3. And if our right
key is present, we increase the value by 0.3. And
whenever our keystroke has been released, we make
sure that the player x coordinate stops changing.
And that is why we have given it the value of zero
to make sure that the spaceship stops and doesn't
go on. And then we just use this arithmetic thing
over here which increases the value of player
x or decreases the value of player x depending
upon the value of this player x underscore change.
So this guy's is looking pretty good in the next
video. If you have any queries please ask them
and questions. So this is pretty much it for this
video. In the next video, we are going to give
our spaceship an enemy because right now is the
space it's looking very lonely for a spaceship.
It's just going in the space and it's not finding
any planets or any enemies. So it's thinking about
its existence and the meaning of life. So what's
happening with me, so we are going to give it a
meaning in the next video. So I'll see you whether
in the last video we learn how to move our
spaceship using our keyboard and the left
hand The right hand side direction. And this
video I was about to give it some enemies.
But then I realized our spaceship is just
moving out of the screen when you go to the
left and when we go to the right. So why is
this happening. So when it goes to the right,
this right border of the spaceship of our game
window, it actually reaches the 800 width that
we have said. And when it goes beyond this 800,
it goes to maybe 810 and 105 pixels. So this no
restriction right now to the spaceship movement
in the left and the right hand side direction.
And similarly, when it moves to the left hand
side, it goes in a little bit lesser than zero
angles goes into minus territory, because this x
coordinate is an integer this that's why it can
go to negatives. And even it can go to minus
450, or something. So what what should we do,
so what we are going to do is that when it teaches
the zero coordinate, then we are going to any time
it goes into negative stuff, we are going to
make sure that it stays at zero by using an if
condition. So we are going to basically tell our
spaceship that, hey, if your x coordinate reaches
zero or less than zero, make sure it turns back
to zero. And similarly on the right hand side,
we are going to tell our spaceship, if your x
coordinate reaches this 800x coordinate path,
then I don't want you to go beyond it and change
your x coordinate to 800 again, so every time it
goes beyond 800, it's going to just delete itself
and go back to 800. But it's going to happen so
quickly that the eyes won't see it. And it will
look like that the spaceship can't go beyond 800.
So let's do that. That's right. And if condition
just beyond this arithmetic operator we have over
here. And as I said, we are just going to write
player x, if this player x becomes less than zero,
that is the x coordinate becomes less than zero,
then we are going to change the value of player
X to zero. And similarly if our let's write f l
f, player x becomes greater than or equal to 736
pixels. So why are we taking this 730 by 36 pixels
instead of 800 pixels. So because our pixel,
we have to take into consideration the size
of our spaceship. So if you remember the PNG
size of the spaceship is 64 by 64 pixels. So the
width of this spaceship is 64 pixels. That is why
we are subtracting 64 from 800. And that means
736 pixels. So if we chose any other number,
for example 800, then it will stop at this point
and not before that, but we wanted to stop over
here and not allow any part of spaceship to
appear beyond the game window. So that's why
we are choosing this 736 pixel number, we
just subtracted 64 from 800. And over here,
we are just going to change the value of whenever
it goes beyond 736 we want it to again go seven to
two back to 730 6x coordinate. And this will mean
that it will look that it cannot go beyond what is
actually but it's just deleting that spaceship and
creating a new one sn 36x coordinate picks it. So
let's check this out. And hopefully it works well.
let's reload it and see if it works or not. So as
you can see when I press the right arrow key
doesn't move beyond this. And feel free to try
it yourself and change the x coordinates just
experiment with it a little bit. So the last
video is pretty long. And this video is pretty
short. So that's good. So in the next video,
we're finally going to create an enemy
for a spaceship so and see you over there.
The last video we learned how to create boundaries
for our spaceship so that it doesn't go out of
bounds. And this video we are going to give it
our first enemies have already downloaded an enemy
image which looks like a happy Space Invader. It's
not going to be so happy when we shoot it with our
spaceship. But anyways, let's get this icon from
flat icon calm just like we always have and search
for Space Invaders. And I'm going to go with this
red space and you can select whatever you want
and download the 64 by 64 picture as usual, and
obviously in the PNG format. So now we can go back
to our code and just like we did with a player,
we can add this enemy dot png inside our code. So
let's do that. Let's just copy this whole code and
just add it below the player change it to enemy.
So we're gonna change everything to enemy so we
just have to rename everything. It's called an
enemy and then I'm just gonna copy and paste this
in the remaining areas. So let's just copy and
paste everything and instead of the player dot png
we are going to call it the enemy dot png and make
sure you rename the PNG file otherwise you tried
if you read enemy dot png is not gonna work. But
anyways, so we need to also create this function
again. So let's just copy and paste this too.
So we're gonna paste this over here instead of
player. We're gonna call it enemy and everything
else should come in the same. Let's format it
properly. Another thing is in PI charm if you want
to format everything properly if you have written
code that's not formatted and doesn't look good,
what you can do is you can just press Ctrl, Alt,
and L, and it will format everything properly
inside your code. So it's just Ctrl L. So as you
can see, it says imports optimized, it will just
make your code look good. So again, the command
is Ctrl, plus alt, plus L on your keyboard. So
anyways, now that we have the function of the
enemy, let's just go down below and add the enemy
over here so that we can call the function while
our while loop is running. So let's add the enemy
over here. And instead of the player x, let's just
call it enemy. And instead of the player x, we're
going to call enemy x. And instead of player y,
we're going to give it a value of and revive. So
right now you can see that the coordinates are the
same as all the spaceships. So this should overlap
our spaceship. So let's see if it's overlapping
or not. So right now, it's not overlapping. Let's,
let's actually check out why is that happening.
So this is because inside our enemy function,
we have not renamed this to enemy dot m g. So
let's do that. Let's rename it enemy dot image,
and then just reload it, and this should work
properly. So now you can see that the enemy is
on top of the spaceship, but he's not we want, we
want the enemy to be like somewhere on the top. So
maybe in the middle, but on the top, so we can
let the enemy x remain the same. But I'm going
to change the enemy y to something else. Let's
give it a value of 50. I've already tried it
out and 50 looks pretty good. So let's see how
it looks. Alright, so our spaceship is moving,
and we have an enemy. But the problem
with this enemy is that it's not moving,
it's very boring. So we're going to fix
that in the next video. But for right now,
what I want is that this enemy should appear in
the random places. So whenever we kill an enemy,
it is going to appear again or in a game terms is
going to respond again. So I wanted to respond in
different places, maybe on different x axis.
So maybe like maybe over here, over here,
update scale, and maybe in y should also appear
in different places. So maybe next time over here,
and it's same over here. So you want it to appear
in different places. So every time it reloads.
Basically, we want it to appear in different
places. And even at the starting of the game,
it should not be constant, it should be totally
random. So what we are going to do is we are
going to make this enemy x and enemy y actually
random. So we have to first write down the line
that actually helps us randomize values. So we
are going to import a package known as random. And
this is pretty easy to do. So let me just minimize
this over here and then scroll down and over here,
we are just going to write instead of 370, we're
just going to write random dot Rand int. So this
is a method inside the random package to choose
a random integer between two values. And then we
have to give it the value that we want. So we want
a starting value and an end value. So in our game,
we want it to appear anywhere between zero and
800. So we are going to give it the starting
value of zero, and the end value of 800. And
similarly with why we wanted to give a value
between maybe 50 and 150. So let's change this to
5050 should be the starting point. So the minimum
height should be 50. And then it can go down over
here, let's say 150. It's approximately 150. So
I'm going to give it a value of 150. Alright guys,
so this is looking pretty good. Let's just try
it again and see if it works. So let's run main.
Alright, so this is working it respond over here,
let's reload it to see if it responds somewhere
else. Let's just reload it and see where this time
it appears. This time it appears over here. Let's
try the third time third time is a charm. And it
always works. So this time it appears over here.
So our program is looking pretty good. We have
created an enemy and it is responding in different
places. So this is just looking pretty good. In
the next video, we are going to make sure that our
enemy moves. So right now our enemy is stationary,
it's not moving from the left or the right and
it's not going down. So we are going to make sure
that we rectify that in the next video is going
to be really exciting. So I'll see you over there.
So in the last video, we created our enemy
and made sure we applied randomization to our
enemies so that when it gets destroyed and created
again it should appear in random places. So as you
can see when we reload our program is going to
respond in a different place. So in this video,
we are going to make sure that our enemy is moving
so imagine that there are multiple enemies right
now there is just when one enemy and we haven't
created multiple enemies, so there is not any
problem. But imagine there are multiple enemies
and they're moving from left to right. And they're
also when they hit the boundary they come a
little bit down. So that's what we are going to be
focusing on today. We are not going to be creating
multiple enemies but we are going to be focusing
on the movement of this one single enemy and then
we can apply it to multiple enemies. But let's for
right now just focus on one enemy. So what exactly
do we want from this enemy? What kind of movement
Do we want. So what we wanted to do is move from
right to left in x direction. So for example,
this enemy will move in the right hand side. And
when it hits the boundary that is about 736 or 800
pixels, it should change its direction and move
towards the left hand side, and when it reaches
the left hand side, then again when it hits that
zero coordinate x coordinate direction, again
changes direction and move towards the right hand
side. So this is the movement in the x direction.
Now there is also a movement in the y direction.
So whenever it hits a boundary, whether it can
be right boundary or the left boundary, then it
should come a little bit down. So that imagine
there are multiple enemies, and we are trying to
shoot all of those enemies down. So how will the
game get over. So whenever these enemies hit the
boundaries and come down at one point of time,
they are going to hit the spaceship as they are
coming down, and then we'll make it Game Over,
like in the classic Space Invaders, so we need to
execute the x movement. And as well as we need to
execute the Y movement, this always is going to
be very easy, because you already know how to move
the spaceship, and we are going to do the same
thing that we did in the player. So first of all,
we will just scroll up, let's minimize this over
here. So we're going to slow up and because our
enemy is going to have the exchange as well as
our y movement. So I'm just going to copy this
over here and also make sure that we add our
by movement. Now enemy exchange over here,
we are going to give it the value of 0.3. Maybe
in future we'll speed it up because a spaceship is
also at the speed of an exchange of 0.3. Maybe
we will change it upon future. But right now
I'm just going to give it a value of 0.3. No, I'm
not giving it a value. So for example, in player,
we haven't, we have just given it a value of zero
over here. And below over here, we have changed
its direction by typing in negative and positive,
we are not going to do this with our enemy
V is going to provide the value of 0.3 over here.
Now if you scroll down, we're just going to do
the same thing that we did with our player. So
for example, over here, we made sure that if it
hit the boundary, so this is the algorithm
basically, you can call it the algorithm,
but it's pretty simple. So whenever it hits the
zero coordinate, we change its value to zero. And
whenever it gets greater than says 36, we make
sure that it coordinates Kate to send 36 again,
and this prevents the spaceship from going out of
bounds. So this is a kind of way of checking the
boundary. So we can do the same thing with our
enemy. So let me just copy and paste this over
here. And instead of everywhere player, we're just
going to call it enemy. So it should be in small.
So over here, also, let me just copy actually and
me and paste it everywhere, this is going to make
sure that we save up some time, not a lot of time.
But so let's face this enemy over here, over here,
I wish there was a quicker way to do it, but
it's not. So anyways, now I'm just going to add a
comment over here so that you guys can understand
what we are talking about over here. So checking
for boundaries of spaceship, so it doesn't go
out of bounds. And over here we're gonna write,
maybe enemy movement, enemy movement. And this
looks pretty good. Instead of restricting us, what
we want is whenever a boundary is hit, we want it
to go someplace. So for example, when it hits that
left boundary, we want to increase the value of
x so that it starts going in the right hand side
direction. And similarly when it hits this right
hand side boundary, then we want to decrease the
value of x. And this will keep on happening
because it's inside our while loop. So now
we are going to use the same arithmetic operation
that we use with our players. So if we scroll up
a little bit, you can see when we wanted to change
directions we gave, when we wanted to move towards
the left, we gave it a value of minus and when
you wanted to move towards the right, we gave it
a positive value of 0.3. And then we just added
because of this arithmetic property. So we are
going to do the same thing over here. So instead
of enemy x equals to zero, what we are going to
do is we are going to write and meet exchange
equals to 0.3. And so that basically when it
hits this left hand side that is zero coordinate,
it can start going towards a positive direction
that is it should start increasing the x value.
And similarly we want when we want it to go left
hand side we are going to change it to a minus
value. So we're going to give it a value of minus
and this should be enough guys. So actually, if I
scroll up, you can see that I've put the value of
enemy x underscore change equals 0.3. We can leave
it to zero or we can leave it as 0.3. It doesn't
really matter. Let's run it and see if it works.
Let me just close down the previous implementation
so that we don't get confused. And I'm just
gonna run it again run main. And hopefully the
enemy will start moving. So you can see that the
enemy is moving from left hand side to right hand
side. And actually, this looks pretty awesome.
So now you can see that it's not moving in the
y direction is just moving in the x direction.
So what we want is that when it hits the right
boundary, it should move downwards. Or even if it
hits the left boundary, it should move a little
bit downwards. So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to go over here, and I'm going to add any y
change equals 240. So that we can move it down by
40 pixels. So why When do we want it to move down,
we want it to move down when it hits the boundary,
that is the geo coordinate or the 736 coordinate,
so we can just increase the value of y over here.
And that should be enough. So I'm just going to
write in me, y plus equals two, and then we want
the enemy y change, just let it let's just paste
over here. And then we can do the same thing over
here. Let's not erase that, we'll just add it over
here. So now let's just reload it and see how it
looks. Now you can see when it hits the boundary,
it actually goes a little bit down. So you can
imagine multiple enemies, when they're hitting the
boundary they are going down. So it's gonna be a
little bit difficult for a spaceship to eliminate
all of them, but it's going to try its best.
And when this enemy reaches the spaceship, we
are going to give it our game over. And depending
upon how many enemies we can hit with our bullet,
which we'll be creating mostly in the next video
or in the coming videos. Depending on how many
enemies he can eliminate with that bullet, the
score is going to be according to that. So you
can kind of get the idea of the game with this
video as to how the game was going to look. So
today we are going to be learning about adding
background image to our PI game. So right now
if we open up our space invader game, you
will be able to see that we have an image
we have in spaceship, but it's happening in the
black background, which doesn't look that good,
we need to add some kind of a space background
to make it very cool. So what I'm going to do is,
I'm already downloaded an image of a background
that is background dot png. And it's some what
looks like this. So how did I get this image. So
what I did was I went to this website fault free
pic.com p ik and then free free pick.com. And
I searched for this text which says colorful
spaceship background. Obviously, feel free to get
an image from wherever you want. But make sure you
get an image that's 800 to 600 pixels wide is that
size, because our game window is of that size.
As you can see, we are made again window of this
area. So what I did was I went over there and you
can choose any of these images. But the image that
I chose was this one, and then I used illustrator,
so free pick is a website was going to give you a
lot of Illustrator Photoshop stuff, and you have
to edit it out to make it your own. So I removed
all of the weird stuff that we didn't want,
for example, this rocket, this text and stuff.
So I removed all of that stuff. And if you know
illustrator, feel free to make a new image on
your own. So what I'm going to do for you guys,
if you're not able to get this image on your own
is that I'm going to attach it to the description
or attach it somewhere so that you guys can
get this image, just look at this videos,
text. So what I'm going to do is after we download
this background image to our project folder,
make sure you do that, then we're just going to
add it to our windows. So over here, how do we
add images to our program is just by pygame dot
image dot load. So I'm going to do that. So I'm
going to add a comment, let's say and we are going
to write just background, just write background.
And then I'm going to create a variable called
background, I'm going to do the same thing
that we did with the wrist. So I'm just going to
copy and paste it over here. And instead of UFO,
I'm going to write background. So obviously my
images of 800 into 600 pixels. So make sure it
is of that size. So now that we have added it,
if we run it right now is not going to appear
because it just appears for a second and then
it disappears, we want it to persist. So how do
we make it persist is by adding it to our while
loop. So we need to make sure that we go to our
while loop over here and we are going to add it
below this screen dot fill because if we don't,
then this black color is going to be on top of our
background image which we don't want. So what I'm
going to do is I'm just going to add another
comment over here. It's gonna say background
image, and we forgot the B's. So let's add B and
then over here, we're just gonna do the screen.
Just typical thing we do when we want to add an
image which is screen, dot blit. So basically
draw the background image and then we need the
variable of the image so that is background.
And then we need to add the coordinates of our
image so we just wanted to appear from the top
left corner severe Going to add zero comma zero.
And that should be pretty good. So let's run our
main.py program, let's run main. And you will
be able to see that our background is there.
But the problem with a background and NP and
a spaceship is now that they are moving very,
very slowly. And why is this so? Pause this video
and figure it on your own territory, pretty cool.
But I'm just gonna explain it over here. So our
background, PNG is actually 226 pixels, sorry,
226 kB, so it's a little bit heavy. But what
happens is when this while loop is running, every
iteration of this while loop previously used to
happen really, really fast. But now because it has
to load this hairy background image, the iteration
of this while loop, every iteration is a little
bit more slow. So that is why whenever we are
increasing the value over here, so for example,
we are increasing the value of player, it is too
small. So whenever this while loop is going, it's
just increasing the value by 0.3, which is very
slow. And that's why it's not able to move around
a lot. So what we are going to do is we are going
to increase the value to five of our players. And
I'm going to change the value of our enemies.
So let's see where as enemies. So here are our
enemies, I'm going to give it a value of let's
say, four, I just want these enemies to be a
little bit slower than aspasia. Because when they
are going to be multiple enemies, then we don't
want them to appear like really, really fast. So
let's reload it now and see if it works. So it's
still slow. Why is this happening? a spaceship
has increased its movement, but the enemy is still
slow. So let's see if somewhere our old values are
still persisting. So enemy we have changed the x
value over here. So let's go up and see where
we have not changed the value. So over here, the
enemy exchange is still 0.3. So we have to change
it over here to let's make it four. And now we can
reload it and you will be able to see that the
enemy is moving at a good speed. So now we have
the background image, we have our spaceship and
we have our enemy. The only thing missing is the
bullets because we don't have the bullets right
now to kill this enemy. So in the next video,
we are going to make our bullets or get started
with making our butt so i'll see you are there.
In this video, we are going to learn how to shoot
our bullet inside our game window. So as you can
see, I'm shooting a bullet and the enemy. So right
now the bullet is not hurting the enemy because we
haven't implemented a collision yet. But more
than that in the future videos. In this video,
we're just going to learn how to shoot a bullet.
So let's get started. But before we get started
with the code, I just wanted to explain a couple
of things. And the first thing I wanted to explain
is what's the starting position of the bullet.
So when we are in the middle of the window that
is at 370 pixel x coordinate approximately,
it's shooting from the top of our spaceship,
but if we move left, it still shooting at the x
coordinate of our spaceship, it doesn't matter
where our spaceship is, the x coordinate of the
bullet is going to be always equal to that of
our spaceship, just the starting positions. For
example, if you shoot the bullet right now, even
if we move our spaceship, the bullet is not moving
with our spaceship, just the starting position of
the bullet is equal to that of our spaceship. So
that is the first thing and the second thing is
that as we shoot the bullet, the bullets of y
value is decreasing. So because at the bottom,
the value is 600 y coordinate, and as we go up the
value of y decreases and add the top is actually
zero. So at the top, the y coordinate of y of a
bullet is going to be zero. So we have to decrease
the value from about 480 pixels. So because this
480 coordinate y coordinate and we are going to
decrease it as we go towards the top. So right now
you can see that it's disappearing at the top. So
the third thing I want to talk about before we go
into code, because it's so important to understand
is the state of the bullet. So right now when
you can't see the bullet its state is at ready.
But when you can see the bullet state is going
to be at file. So right now it's not appearing
on the screen. That is That means that we are
reading the bullet for fire. And when it shoots,
you can see the bullet and that means the bullet
has been fired. So let's not do between that
firing period anything. So this is what it means.
Obviously, we are going to understand this more as
we write down the code. So let's get started
with that. So the first thing we need to do
is add an image of a bullet inside our project
folder now already added as you can see on the
left hand side bullet dot png, and it kind of
looks like this. So how can you get this image
so you can just go to flat icon.com like we have
done previously and searched for this bullet. And
you can just download this bullet from here. And
obviously you can choose any bullet that you want,
and even through Google or something but make
sure when you download this image it's 32 by
32 pixels. This bullet is not the same as I'm
using but if you want you can just go to the
sixth or seventh page of this flat icon.com and
you will find the same image but feel free to use
this image it doesn't make a lot of difference.
So now we have downloaded this bullet PNG make
sure it's 32 by 32 pixels. Let me just close
this Photoshop. This is the background, we made
the last video. So after adding the bullet dot
png, we are going to add it into our byte code.
So over here just below the enemy, we're just
going to copy this enemy because we don't want
to create everything again. And instead of enemy,
we're just gonna write bullet. And we are going to
replace everything of our enemy with our bullets.
So let's call it a bullet. And then I'm just
going to copy and paste everything. So politics
bullet why and just paste it but at exchange,
and some of these values we are not going to use.
So for example, bullet is not going to move in the
x direction. So using this x underscore change is
useless. But still, we are going to just keep it
over here just for this sake of conformity.
But anyways, in this bullet x and bullet y,
we are going to give the value of zero bullet
x because we are going to be changing the value
inside our while loop. But bullet y is going to be
at 480 pixels. Why is that because our spaceship,
as you can see as clear why is at 480 pixels.
So at that level, the bullet is always going to
be short. And so if I run this main program over
here, you can see that a spaceship is over here.
And what's happening to her enemy, let's reload
it. Let's see if we have done something to enemy
No. So as you can see, when we move, our spaceship
is not moving in the y direction, so we need to
shoot our bullet from its top of his nose, which
is at 480 pixels of y coordinate. That's why we
have code and this 480 over here. And then we are
going to add another variable which is going to be
bullet state. So this is the state I was talking
about a few seconds ago. So we are going to add
a variable bullet state and we are going to give
it a value of ready. So let me just add a comment
actually over here so that you guys remember what
this release date is what is y est. So readystate
basically means you can't see the bullet on the
screen. And fire. So bullet is currently moving.
Alright, so this is the state we are going to be
using to basically differentiate between whether
the bullet is in motion or it's in a state of
constant and it's not being fired right now is
going to help us decide the movement dynamics of
our bullet. So now we have created another bullet
state equals ready and now we are going to create
a function known as fire bullet that is going to
be called whenever we press our spacebar. So in
our game, when we press our spacebar of bullet
is being fired, so that is what you want. And
pressing the spacebar when it gets fired. So and
what happens when we press spacebar, we want this
function of fire underscore bullet to be called.
And we are going to do the same thing over here we
are going to call the x and y variables. And just
below that, we are going to access this bullet
underscore state variable equals to ready inside
our function. Now how do you do that, we need
to create this bullet underscored state function
as global so that it can be accessed inside this
function. So I'm just gonna write global and then
call it state. And now we can access the value
of this bullet state from inside this function.
So after this, after we press space, the bullet
is actually being fired. So now you can see it
on that screen. So we need to change the state of
the bullet equals to file. So now it's not ready,
it's actually being fired currently in motion.
After that, we just need to make sure that it
appears on the screen. So I'm going to write
skinning dot plate, we need to draw the bullet
on the screen. And then I'm going to write the
name of our bullet image bullet image. And then
we are going to write the coordinates of where do
we want it to appear. So we just wanted to appear
on x comma y the values that you are getting
from the function. Now we want this values to be
at x plus 16 and y plus 10. Why is that? So let me
just format everything properly. And you can press
Ctrl Alt plus L if you're using pi charm to make
sure that it looks good. So why are we doing this
Xpress 16 why plus 10. This is to make sure that
the bullet appears on the center of our spaceship,
if you don't do plus 16 is going to appear on
the left hand side of the spaceship a little
bit. I've already tried it out. So that's why a
note section is the correct value. And this Why
is just make sure that it appears a little bit
above spatial just to give it an illusion of the
bullet being fired from the top of the nose and
not from the center of the spaceship. And now
before we go into the while loop, I just want
to change the value of change in y because I'm
pulling is moving in the right direction. And
this is the value that we give to the enemy.
We don't want the bullet to move this fast we want
it to move at the speed of 10. So let's close this
window now. And let's just go below and what we
want over here is that if an arrow key of space,
not an arrow key, if a keystroke or space on
our keyboard is pressed, then we want to call
that fire underscore bullet function. So let's
create that over here so that we can just copy
and paste this line. And then at the end, we can
just add the value of space, okay, underscore
space. And this is going to make sure that we can
capture the value of space. And what we want when
you press a space, we want the Firebird function
to be called. And now what are the values inside
this. So right now we are going to give it
a value of clear eggs. But you'll understand
why this is strong. But this is just like a logic
error. So I'm not gonna worry about it too much,
but I'm gonna tell you why it's strong. And we
are going to fix this in this video. So let's try
it if event dot key pygame dot k underscore space
fire underscore bullet player x comma, y. So let's
run this right now and see how it looks. Obviously
it's not complete, not even close to complete,
but we're gonna it's gonna look how it looks. So
right now you can see bullet is not there. But
when we press the space, nothing is happening and
the enemies appearing for some reason. Over here,
if you speak, if you've seen yet near the
spaceship, the enemy is appearing, because we
haven't changed the name of our image. So let's go
to the bullet. And over here instead of enemy we
are going to call it bullet. I know when I was
recording this and you I was just writing the
slide, you guys must have screamed that, hey, this
should be bullet dot png not enemy dot png word,
no worries, we have changed the value. And if we
come back, you can see that you can't really see
the bullet over here. But it's actually appearing
but it's appearing so fast that you can't see it.
So actually, let me just change it to enemy
again so that you guys can at least see it.
It's happening behind the screen. So let me run
this. And when we press face, you can see that
the enemy is appearing at near the spaceship, you
can see this, this is happening. So this is how
the bullet is also appearing. But right now you
just can't see it. So let's change this back to
bullet dot png. To put a dot png so we need to
do a couple of things. So why is it appearing
and disappearing so quickly, what we need to do
is we need to make sure that it persists in the
background. And when we need anything to persist
in pygame, we added to our infinite while loop. So
right now this code is only being called when we
press the spacebar we want this bullet to appear
and not disappear really really quickly. So we
are going to add another comment over here. And
we're going to call this bullet movement bullet
movement. And over here, we are going to just
change the values and first check the maybe the
state of our bullet. So right now our state is
when you press the spacebar, then the state
changes to fire. But at default, the state
always remains at ready. So as you can see that
the bullet underscore state is equal to ready. And
when we press the spacebar, the fire underscore
grid function is called and inside the function,
the state changes to file. So outside over here we
can write and condition if bullet state is fire,
then we can actually move the bullet in front of
the spaceship and make sure it decreases in y.
So we're going to add some values and we're going
to call this Fireblade function again over here,
and we're going to get rid of value of clear x,
and we're going to give it a value of y. And just
below this, we are going to decrease the value of
our bullet just like we discussed at the starting
of the video, minus plus minus equal minus equal
to bullet y change which is currently 10. So let's
run this program now and see if it works. So this
is our spaceship and what's happening to our enemy
y is going crazy. Let me just reload this what's
what's up with this enemy. Alright, so now you can
see that the bullet is moving. But this this there
are two problems in this first, we can only fire
one bullet. So you can see after we have fired one
bullet, we can't fire another bullet. So that's
one problem. And the second problem is that when
we fire the bullet, when we move our spaceship,
the bullet is moving with aspiration. Just to
give you guys another view, when you press space
the bullet is going and when we move the spaceship
the bullet is actually moving with the spaceship.
So we will be solving both of these problems in
the next video. For right now I'm just going to
give you a recap so that you guys can understand
properly what is going on. So let's go The moment
you press the spacebar, so when you press the
spacebar, this event of spacebar is triggered and
this fire grid function is called. And over here
we sent two values that is the current position of
player x and a bullet y value. The bullet y value
is for at y coordinate and the player x is the
movement where the spaceship is the x coordinate
of the spaceship and that is partly the reason
why the bullet is moving in the direction of the
spaceship but we are going to tackle that in the
next video. So for right now we are calling this
fire bullet function whenever the space key is
pressed, and we're transferring the value of
player x and bullet y to our fire underscore
unit function. Now this fire blade function is
due to changing the state of our bullet state
underscore to fire so that when we execute this
y loop All this code can be executed. So we are
finding firing the bullet and to find the ability
first need to show it on the screen. So we are
blurting it out or drawing it on the screen. And
we have changed the value of 16. And why. So just
to show you guys why we have changed the values,
let me actually remove the x and y values, so that
you guys can see the difference. So I'm just going
to turn play and I'm going to shoot a bullet. As
you can see, the bullet is being shot a little
bit from the left hand side and we want it to
be shot from the middle of the screen. That is why
I did that. So the middle of the spaceship not in
the from the middle of the screen to be exact. But
anyways, after we did this fire in this corporate
function has been called the bridge state has
been returned to fire. And then we go to this
infinite while loop which is running but it wasn't
running because before running the spacebar or
before pressing the spacebar, the bullet state
was ready. So all of this code was not getting
executed. But after pressing the spacebar, the
bullet state has been changed to fire. So now we
can put blade this out on the screen by calling
this fire unders component function. And we can
start actually changing the location of the bullet
by moving it in the upward direction by reducing
the value of y. So guys, this was the logic of
our bullets. In the next video, we are going to
tackle the two problems that we have discussed
in this video. So I'll see you over there.
The last video we learned how to shoot a
bullet. But there are a couple of problems
with our program right now we can shoot only
one bullet at a time. And that said that's it
for the whole game has a pretty big problem. And
the second problem is that the bullet is always
following our spaceship doesn't matter where it
goes, bullet will follow it and we want it to
have an individual path. So for example, we wanted
to have, we want the bullet to have the starting
point of our spaceship, the x coordinate our
spaceship, but when we move the spaceship,
that bullet should continue on its original x
coordinate and not of our current spaceship. So
these are two problems we are going to solve.
Let's solve the first problem first of having
multiple bullets. So for that, what we are going
to do is we are going to add an if condition.
So right now, if you watch over here, when the
bullet goes up, it goes to the zero coordinate,
and then we are not doing anything to a bullet. So
it just keeps on going into negative values. And
we are not removing the bullet from our screen.
So what we need to do is as soon as it crosses
the zero coordinate, we need to make sure that it
resets to the value of 480. So as soon as soon as
it goes above zero coordinate, two things are
going to happen first is going to reset to 480
pixels of y. And the second thing is because you
can't see it on the screen anymore, because it
has gone beyond zero y coordinate, we are going
to change the state of a bullet to ready again,
so that we can fire it the next time. So let me
just add an if condition this beneath this bullet
movement, which says if bullet y is less than
equals to zero because above zero is going to
be negative values. And over here we are going to
do two things. First is we are going to reset the
state of the bullet that is the bullet Why should
be reset it to 480 again, and the second thing is
we need to change of the bullet state. So bullet
state is going to be ready again. And let's make
sure that we don't misspell anything. And we are
going to format this properly. Press Enter and
now let's reload it and you will be able to see
that our bullet is multiple. So right now you can
see we are short one bullet, then we can shoot
another bullet and it keeps on happening. And
now that we have fixed the first problem, let's
focus on the other problem. And that is that the
bullet is following our spaceship. So why is this
happening? This is happening because in our code,
we are still using the player x value. So if we go
to our space condition, so after pressing space,
we are using the player x value. And even
in our bile if condition code of over here,
we are still using the player x value. So it's
alright that we want the starting position of our
bullet to be at the spaceship that we just removed
this recording thing. So at the starting position,
we want the bullet to be at the x coordinate
of a spaceship. So when you press space,
the bullet starts from the spaceship and not
from somewhere else. So for example, over here,
we want to x coordinate of a bullet to be that
of the x coordinate of our spaceship. But when
we move after firing the spaceship, the x
coordinate shouldn't follow the spaceship.
So that is the problem that we are having. So how
do we solve that. So instead of using the bullet,
the space player x value everywhere, which is just
use when you press the spacebar, one value of the
x coordinate just should be just saved. So we're
gonna do that we're just going to write bullet x,
we haven't used this variable yet. And we are
going to save the value of player x over here.
And then instead of player x, we are going to send
the value of bullet X to our fire bullet function.
And we are going to do the same thing over here
in our if condition so instead of player x,
you're going to use the value of bullet x and
that should solve the problem. So let's run our
main program again and see if it works. So this
is a spaceship. And now if we move our spaceship,
the bullet is not following our spaceship. So,
we had what we have done is when the spacebar is
pressed, then we are saved the current spaceship x
coordinate inside our bullet X variable. And then
we are using that everywhere instead of just using
player x. So now that we have fixed that there is
one more problem to fix, which I've just realized.
So the problem is that after pressing if we press
the spacebar again, so for example, we press
the spacebar, the bullet is going. And then if
you press the spacebar multiple times this bullet
is going to change just keep on moving according
to our spaceship. So multiple spacebar changes
its x coordinate. And why is that happening. So
while the bullet is a moving condition, it's in
fire condition. Even in that condition, we can
press our spacebar, so we have to make sure that
we can only press the spacebar when it's in ready
condition. So we're going to add a if condition
over here, which says if bullet state is ready,
let's add double quotes for the string. If
the police state is steady, only then we can
fire another bullet, otherwise we can't fire the
bullet. So after our bullet goes above this zero
coordinate or our bullet is in ready state only
then we can fire another bullet. So now if you
play space, all the errors have been fixed. Except
this first one, I don't know what happens to is
sometimes. Alright, so let's shoot. And you can
see that after it has crossed the zero coordinate,
and it resets to 40 y coordinate again, only then
we can shoot another bullet. So this is looking
pretty good guys, we have finally completed the
bullet module. This was a pretty long module
because there were a lot of complications in it
and a lot of things to understand. So let me just
recap so that you guys can understand everything
properly. So if anybody has understood everything
perfectly, you guys can just stop this video.
So what happens when you press the spacebar,
when you press the spacebar First, it checks
whether a bullet is already on the screen or not.
If it's not on the screen, then it makes sure that
it gets the x coordinate of our spaceship, let me
just add a comment so that you guys can understand
get the current x coordinate of the spaceship. So
it gives the current x coordinate of the spaceship
and stores it inside this variable bullet x and
then it fires the bullet using this bullet X
variable. And this bullet Y variable basically
which we have said before that is 10 because we
want the bullet to move at the speed of 10 or
change its y value at every vile iteration at 10.
So after we do that it goes to this fire bullet
function and over there it changes the state to
fire and then it creates that bullet. After it
changes its state to fire it goes to this while
loop iteration I checked, it says if bullet state
is fire, and it keeps on firing the bullet. If we
don't have this fire underscore bullet statement,
then the bullet won't appear on the screen. So
anything that we want to be persisted inside, our
game needs to be included inside our while loop.
That is why we have this function inside our while
loop. If this statement was not there, the bullet
wouldn't be there. So that is why we need to make
sure that the bullet is continuously appearing on
the screen after every iteration of while loop. So
after it fires a bullet it keeps on changing
its y coordinate. Because of this statement,
it happens that it goes above the screen. So
after it goes above the screen this if condition
is activated, and it resets the bullet to 480 y
coordinate and then it resets the bullet state to
ready again. And then we can press the spacebar
again and everything happens again. Basically,
it's saved again the x coordinate of a spaceship
but I'm not going to go into all of that. So guys,
that is pretty much it for this video.
In the next video we are going to create
multiple enemies. So right now there is only
one enemy so it's very easy for our spaceship,
or maybe depending upon what I want. And
maybe I'm going to teach you guys how to
shoot this enemy. So right now this enemy
can pass through the bullet and nothing
is happening to him. So we are going to
probably discuss that in the next video.
So in the last video, we created multiple
bullets, instead of shooting just one bullet,
we can shoot multiple bullets at the enemy and
we don't have to, you know, just just shoot one
bullet during the whole game. But as you can see,
our bullet is going through the enemy and it's
not colliding and nothing is happening when the
bullet hits the enemy not the score is increasing
and the enemy is also at the same place. It's not
responding anywhere, which we want. So in this
video, we are going to learn about the collision
concept how to make sure that the two objects have
collided. And that's a very important concept in
gaming. So what do We'll be doing is that let me
just actually reload this game so that we can see
the bullet and the enemy properly. So what I'm
going to be doing is we are going to calculating
the distance between the bullet and the enemy.
And if the distance is short enough, then we
conclusively say that the bullet has collided.
So the bullet has an X and Y coordinates where
it goes up through the screen. And similarly,
this enemy also has an X and Y coordinate, when it
goes through the screen on left, right or up and
down. So we are going to use all of these four
coordinates, that is the x coordinate and the x
coordinate of our bullets and the y coordinates
of both our bullet and an enemy to calculate the
distance between them. So now what I want you
guys to do is go to Google and type in distance
between two coordinates. And we're gonna take you
to this website math planet.com. And over here,
there is this equation, which says distance
equals to x coordinate minus x coordinates of
other objects squared plus y coordinate of one
object and y coordinate of the object square,
and then a square root of the whole thing. And
this x two and x one doesn't matter, whatever is
at front because and by the end of the day, we are
squaring this. So obviously, you must have learned
this in school or in college. But if you haven't,
don't worry about it, just go through this article
a little bit, you just need to execute this code
in this equation in our Python. So even if you
don't understand what this is doing, we are going
to learn how to actually implement our equation
in Python. So that is going to be really helpful
for you guys. So keep this equation in mind. And
let's go back to our code, and just beneath this
fire underscore bullet function, we are going to
create a new function, and we're gonna call it is
coalition. So this function is basically going to
help us with define whether a collision between
the bullet and an enemy has occurred or not. So
he's going to take four values, the x coordinate
of the enemy, the y coordinate of the enemy,
the x coordinate of the bullet, and similarly,
the y coordinate of our bullet. And now we are
going to create a variable known as distance, so
this distance will store the distance between the
bullet and our enemy. And how do we calculate
this distance, obviously, using this equation,
so distance equals two, and then we're gonna
do a square root. So to do a square root, or do
any kind of mathematical operations, you need to
import something known as math. So if you go up,
I haven't imported math yet. So I'm just gonna
write import math. So I'm going to import that.
And then First of all, we want to do the square
root. So let me go over here and just write
math.sq Rt. So this is the basically the function
or the method for doing square root, and then
apply some brackets. Now we need the Nv x and the
bullet x, and we need to subtract it according to
the formula. But before we even that, we need to
square it. So if we go back to our equation, you
can see after the square root, the x two minus x
one is being squared. So we also need to implement
that mathematical formula. So we're just gonna
write math dot POW. So this stands for power,
and then it requires two values, the x and the y.
So we're going to do that. So we're going to just
write comma two, because we want it to be squared,
and then over here, we are going to give it the
value of enemy x minus enemy y. Alright, so this
is looking good, we have executed the first part
of our equation, now we have to execute the second
part of the equation that is plus y two minus
y one and two squared. So we are going to go
back over here and inside our math.pi. So this
is this part math.pi x two, and this is enemy,
not any y. This is politics, sorry about that.
And then we are just going to write plus, and
then we are going to write math dot POW again,
because we need another power and requires to two
values first is the par value, so we want it to be
squared again. And then we just need to subtract
the anyway when you move y and me y minus bullet
y. And this should give us the value. Obviously,
we need to close this Math Math dot square root,
so we're going to apply another bracket but looks
like it's an extra bracket. So what we are doing
is math dot pow, we are doing x two minus x one or
x minus x one minus x doesn't matter, squared it
and then math.pa y two minus y one squared. So
just to make sure that these two are separate,
we are going to apply another bracket over here.
So I'm going to also do this with this one. Let's
not blunder Alright, so there is some problem
over here. So this is the problem. So let's
apply a bracket over here instead of that,
and this is looking pretty good. So now what
we are going to do is we are going to write an if
condition if this distance is less than 27 pixels,
then return us the value of true that is the
collision has occurred, else return us the value
of false. So we're going to write f condition and
return false. I mean, we didn't need to write the
Save condition. We could have just return false
over here, but I just wanted to make sure that
you guys understood. All right, let's format
it properly obviously immunity format meeting
in PI charm, make sure you press Ctrl Alt plus L
LS for I don't know Lula something. So make sure
you press Ctrl Alt plus L if you're using Python,
it should format everything beautifully. Alright,
so our escalation function is complete.
So now what we are going to do is,
we are going to scroll down, and we are going to
write inside our while infinite loop over here,
just below this enemy x or even the politics, we
are going to add a comment that's going to stand
for collision so that we know that we are
writing the code for collision. And over here,
we can just check whether a collision is happening
or not. So I'm going to create a variable called
collision and then I'm going to call this
escalation function. And over here, we are
going to set the value of enemy x and y. And over
here in all of this code inside this while loop,
we are manipulating the value of x and y of
enemy and the bullet. So this is the right
place to call this escalation function. So here we
are just going to write bullet x comma y. Alright,
so this is looking good. So this is collision is
going to store the value of true and false and if
the collision has occurred is going to store the
value of collision of true in collision. Alright,
so this is looking good. And then we're going
to write a condition if condition. So what do
you want us to do if the collision is occurring?
Basically, that is what our program is asking. So
what do we want after a collision has occurred.
So the first thing that we want is to reset the
bullet to its starting point. So we are going
to reset the bullet y at 480. And then because
the bullet is not being shown anymore, we want to
change the state of the bullet to ready. So let's
change the state of the bullet to ready by writing
bullet state equals to reading. And then the last
thing we want to do is obviously increase the
score. So I'm just going to create a new variable,
let's say, let's actually just go over here so
that it's close by and we are going to write
the value of score equals to zero. All right, so
that's looking pretty good. So I'm going to just
scroll down, and over here, I'm going to write
score score by missing the variable of score
squared plus equals to one. So this will increase
the value by one every time we hit our enemy. And
after that, we are just going to print out our
score. So I'm just going to print it out on the
screen. So now let's just run our program and
see if everything is working or not. So I'm just
going to run the main program. And over here, we
are going to shoot our bullets. And hopefully,
if it hits, and I'm not a bad player, as you can
see the score increased by one. So let's try to
hit it again. And as you can see, the score is
increasing by one. But when we are not hitting it,
the score is not increasing. So let's try
to make our score at least five. All right,
all right, so the score is five. So what one
thing you must have noticed is that the enemy
is still on his current path. And it's not
responding to its default location. So we
need to fix that. So what we are going to do is we
are going to right change the value of player x,
the enemy x and the enemy by over here. So I'm
just gonna scroll up and check out where we have
declared the value of enemy x and y. So I'm just
going to copy this, and I will paste this inside
our F collision, obviously, like this code can
be optimized, we can create a new function for
all of this stuff that is happening over here.
But maybe we can do that in the later videos,
all the optimization classes and functions, we'll
see whether we do that or not, because this is not
such a complicated program. But maybe we will. So
now what will happen is that the enemy x and the
enemy y will get restarted or respond to a default
location, and will respond to a random integer
that is between zero to 800. And why is 50 to 150.
Obviously, we already discussed what this does, it
basically gives a default position to the enemy.
So let's give it a shot again. And we're gonna run
the mean again and see if it works. So let me just
wait for it. Alright, so our enemy is actually
just going back to its new location. Alright,
let's just wait for the enemy to come back a
little bit down so that we know that our code
is working properly. So let's shoot it. Alright,
so our game is responding properly, our enemies
respond properly, and it looks good. So one
thing you might have noticed that when it comes to
this right hand side of the screen, it just drops
down. Even if you're trying it on your own. If an
enemy response towards the right hand side of that
window of a window, it just goes down. So why is
that happening? that is happening because when we
respond our enemy or just be when you're creating
the movie or giving it a value of zero to 800. And
but inside our code we have written in over here
that if the enemy x is greater than 736, make sure
you change its y value. So there will whenever
our enemy is responding with a greater value than
736 it's immediately going down without a chance
to go left. That's why we need to make sure that
over here when we are creating the enemy that
we don't increase the value till 800 only it is
736 Just for safety, we are going to write 735. So
obviously, we need to make sure that the same 35
also goes in when a collision has occurred. So I'm
just going to copy that over here too. Alright, so
this looks good. We have also fixed an error. So
this is looking pretty good. Alright. So Alright,
look enemies responding properly. Let me just
shoot it again. All right. So alright guys. So
this is pretty much it for this video. In the
next video, we are going to learn how to create
multiple enemies. So right now there is only
one enemy. So the game is pretty easy, you can
just play it really easy, and actually is pretty
fun to play. While I'm recording this video i'm
also playing. But anyway, guys, let me just recap
actually quickly so that you guys can understand.
So if you already understand the video, just
go to the next video, but for people who have
not understood properly, so we have created a
function called is collision where you have four
coordinates to off enemy coordinates and to have
bullet coordinates. And we have used all of these
four coordinates in this formula, which we got
from typing and distance between two coordinates
this formula and then we try to execute this
formula inside our code. Obviously, before
you shall start doing this man thought squad,
make sure that you import math. And after that,
we made the square root. And then inside this
week, using the dot POW function, we squared it
just like we have done in this formula x two minus
x squared squared. So we needed to make sure that
we squared it and make sure that the brackets are
correctly placed. Because if you guys are typing
the code, it might like it might you might mess
up somewhere. So make sure you guys are typing
this code properly, line by line. All right, all
obviously, I will upload all this code on GitHub,
so you'll find it somewhere over there. And by the
end of this series, I'll upload it after recording
all the videos. So you can wait for it a little
bit or you can find it in the description or
attachments or something. So math.pi and e x minus
bullet x, you guys understand all of this stuff,
and then how this 27 network number came to be. So
I just tried and tested what was the proper number
for distance between enemy and bullet to call
it a collision. And I just by trial and testing,
I came on this number if the distance between
the bullet and the enemy is less than 27,
I'm going to call it a collision. And then if
the collision has occurred, it will return true
and obviously we are calling this function over
here if collision. So if a collision has occurred,
what do we want from a program, we first of all,
we want to reset the vials of blood to 480 that is
the starting position of the spaceship and then
we are going to change the state of course to
ready because you can't see the bullet anymore.
And when you can't see the bullet anymore, the
state is ready. And then we increase the score by
one and we printed out the score and then we made
sure that the enemy respond to its new location.
Alright guys, so this is basically a way to just
to track back a little bit this is just a way to
kill the enemy and then make sure that we also
create a new enemy. Alright guys, that's pretty
much it for this video. Thank you for hanging out
in the next video we are going to learn how to
create multiple enemies, so I'll see you there.
In this video, we are going to learn how to create
multiple enemies. And in the previous video,
we learned about how the collision system works.
So for example, if we shoot the enemy is going
to respond to a new place, as well as increase
our score. So how do we make sure that multiple
enemies appear on a screen so for example, six
enemies so what we can do one idea is that we can
store all of these six enemies in a list or an
array but in Python is called a list. So we are
going to store all of the enemies in a list and
display them one by one on the screen. But it's
going to happen so fast that it will look that
all the six enemies are appearing simultaneously
on the screen. So we are going to turn all of
these variable into a list variable and how do
you do that you simply copy the variable name
and equal to and brackets. So this signifies
an empty list. There is nothing inside this list
and we are going to use a for loop to put values
inside this list. But we have to do it with all
of the variables. So let's do that. So let's do
it with enemy x and then enemy y. So I'm gonna
copy this, copy this paste over here. Let me
just copy everything first and then I'm going to
add the square brackets not the neatest way but
the quickest way and then I'm just gonna copy
all of these square brackets quickly. Alright,
and how do you add values inside a list so
right now this is an empty list and how do you
add values to a list is by using a method known
as dot append. So instead of equals two we are
going to use dot append over here. But even before
that we are going to create a variable known as
num of enemies which stands for number of enemies
and we can change this variable whenever we want
to increase the number of enemies. So we are going
to create a for loop for i in range and inside
this we are in a port number of enemies. So this
loop for right now is gonna run six times and six
of our enemies are gonna be created. Obviously you
we want all of these values to be out added to the
list that we have created of all the variables.
So what we are going to do instead of equal to,
we are going to write dot append. And this is
going to add our current value inside our list.
So for example, the first enemy image is going to
be stored inside this enemy image list. So we are
going to do all of this with all of the variables.
And you don't need to do it with any new via
change because these are like constant values,
but whether just for the sake of simplicity,
we are going to do it with all of them.
Alright, so let me just do it with all of them,
I'm going to copy this dot append everywhere. So
just to do it quickly, again, not the neatest way,
but the quickest way and that is what we want,
just the quickest way. And let me just add the
practice after everyone so that there are no
errors. And it looks neat. Alright guys, so
this is looking pretty well. So whenever our code
is going to run, it's going to go through this,
and it's gonna create six number of enemies.
But if you scroll down inside our while loop,
you can see that we don't specify which enemy x
do we want to move. So this is the code that we
are using for the enemy to move towards the left
hand side or the right hand side and a downward
movement. But if we don't specify which enemy x
we are talking about, because if you notice above,
we have declared six enemy x. And because we
have created a variable called as enemy x we have
created an empty list. So each time this for loop
is going to run is going to enter a new value of
enemy x and scientists and we x list. So we need
to make sure that our program understands which
enemy x we are talking about. So we are going to
create another for loop over here and we're going
to do the same thing that we did over there number
of enemies. And the idea is pretty intuitive,
you just need to change every value over here to
basically inside a square bracket just specify
which value you're talking about. And this is a
way to reference something inside a list obviously
if you know less you probably already know about
this. So anyways, we are going to do this we are
going to I this I bracket everywhere. So let me
just copy and paste this everywhere so that our
program knows which anyway we are talking about
which enemy wide change we are talking about. Let
me just copy this everywhere. All right, this is
looking pretty good. And then we also need to make
sure that a collision is also inside our enemy.
So we are going to copy all of this code from
over here. And we are going to place this inside
our while loop because we need to make sure that
we calculate the collision for every let me just
paste this so you can see over here that currently
our collision is it's not inside our for loop but
actually inside here it's actually inside a for
loop but make sure that it's not inside this
lF condition or the if condition otherwise,
it's not going to work a lot of people make this
mistake that they don't pace the collision part
correctly or don't pace anything properly. So
anyways after making sure that you have pasted
is probably inside our for loop we are also going
to change these let me just press it here alzette
we are going to make sure that our Python
program knows which and the x coordinates
we are talking about. So let me just paste it
over here. Alright, so this is looking pretty
good. We also need to make sure that we add
it over here. So basically, wherever we are
talking about the enemy or the coalition, you
need to make sure that our program knows which
coordinate or which enemy we are talking about.
And then the last thing we need to do is whenever
we are calling the enemies for example over here
calling the enemy function and this is where we
will basically blitting the enemy we also need
to make sure that we add which image do we want
to be plated. So right now it's not specifying
so we are going to paste this inside our ennemi
for loop and make sure it's not post pasted inside
the if condition it's pasted inside our loop. So
indentations matter and then we are going to send
the value of i according with specifying which x&y
coordinates we want to be printed on the screen.
So basically which enemy we are talking about.
So if we go up to our enemy function over here
you can see we haven't specified the AI value so
we need to specify the value and also the which
image enemy image do we want to draw? Obviously,
you will be thinking there's only one image but
actually there are six enemy images because we
have created a list of enemy images too,
as you can see over here. Alright guys,
so this is looking pretty good. I think almost
all of the code is done. So let me just play it
and then we will figure out what we have to recap
and if there are any errors, we can solve them.
So let's play it and see if it works. Alright,
so this is looking pretty good. We have created
six enemies and when we showed them so let's try
and shoot one of them amateur bad player. Alright,
so when we are shooting them, our collision is
also working. It's they are responding. Alright,
so this is looking pretty good. So how is
this game going to end whenever one of these
Space Invaders come and hit the bottom of
the spaceship or basically hit the 480 by
access then we are going to end the game so we
just keep shooting and increase the score. And
right now there is no place where we are
displaying the scores. In the next video,
we are going to make sure that we display
the score on the left hand side top corner.
All right, guys, welcome back. So in the
last video, we created multiple enemies,
and our game is looking real, real good. So the
score system is working, but the score is not
being currently displayed on our game window.
So we'll fix that in this video, we will make
sure that the score appears on the top left
corner of our screen. So how do you do that,
so that is simple, we use a font object that is
inside pygame. So pygame is actually going to help
us create font or text on the screen. So the first
thing we need to do is go to this word image. And
we are going to actually remove the score variable
that we've created over here. So instead of that,
we are going to just press enter and write score
so that we know we are creating score under this
statement. And then right now we are going to
create a variable known as core value, and we're
going to give it a value of zero. And obviously,
you can see with this red symbol, there is some
error with say a score plus one, we are doing
it over here. So we need to change this to score
value. And then we can remove the print statement
because we don't need it down. So let's just go up
now. And then we have to use the score object or
the PI game font object. So that is pretty easy.
You just create a variable known as font. And
obviously you probably know already, what font is,
font is just the type of text or the style of
text that is displayed how much the weight of
the line often is, is actually dependent upon
the font, what kind of font you use. So first,
we are going to define what kind of font we want.
So how do you do that, we just use the pygame dot
font method that is inside pygame pygame dot font
dot capital F font and inside this we are going
to give it two values. The first is which font Do
we want. So inside pygame, there is one free font
which is known as free. cents bold. So right now
we are just going to use this font and dot TTF is
the extension of the font. And then we are going
to give it a size. So we're just going to give it
a size of 32. And then after that we are going to
give it the x and y coordinates of where we want
this text to appear. So we want it to appear
in that top left corner somewhere, but not
just attached the screen a little bit away from
the scheme. So we are going to give it a value of
text text the x coordinate of 10 pixels, and then
text y of that is the y coordinate also of 10. Now
just like we did with these player player enemies,
we have to create a function that is going to show
this score value on the screen. So let's do that
we are going to create a function which we are
going to call show score. Pretty easy stuff. And
inside this function, we have to give it the X
and Y value just like we have done with everything
else. And one difference is that for example, you
can see how we are plotting the image inside this
def player. Instead of creating the player trying
the player on the screen, we are going to render
the text on the screen. So I'll just show you
what I mean by that. So we're going to create a
variable of score. And inside this we are going to
write font dot render. And we're going to require
some values inside it. So this is the what I mean
by instead of bleeding, we are going to render the
text of show the text on the screen. So using this
font object we have created over here we are now
right font on trend. And there is going to require
a couple of values the first value is what text Do
you want. So we want our text to be first of all
score. And then we want the score value in front
of the text. So we are going to write it actually
we have to convert it into a string. So right
now, this score value is an integer, so we have
to use typecasting and inside this. So basically
we are converting this integer value to a string
by writing str in front of it. This concept in
Python is known as typecasting and actually, in
programming This concept is known as type casting.
So inside this we are gonna write score value. And
then after that the second value is required is
true. So we can display it on the screen. And
then the third value requires is what is the color
of the font that you want, you can show whatever
color you want. Obviously, we have to use the RGB
values, which we have discussed before. But I'm
just going to use the white whether that is 255
or eight 255 green, and then 255 blue. So this
is looking pretty good. Let me just format this
properly. And then we are going to show it on the
screen and how do you show it on the screen.
So first, we are going to render the score
called render the text. And then we have to blit
this text on the screen or draw this text on the
screen. That is why I said this is a little bit
different. First you have to render then you have
to break it on the screen. So we are going to use
the same concept we have over here. So actually,
let me just copy this from here and paste it and
instead of image we are going to render our score.
So this time is not an image it's a font or a
text and it requires X and Y value which we are
providing through this function. And now one
last step. That we have to do is pretty easy,
we just have to go down and anything that you
want to persist on our screen obviously has to
be called inside our while loop. So I'm just gonna
call our show score function and x, y is text x,
and text y. Alright guys, so this is looking
pretty easy. So let me just run it and show you
that it works. And hopefully it will run without
any errors. So our score is displayed on the top
left corner. And when we shoot someone, let me
just show someone as you can see, our score is
increasing. So let me just shoot a couple of more
enemies or space invaders. Alright guys, so this
is looking pretty good. Our score is increasing
and resolving respond and our game is being
created. So one last thing I want to tell you guys
is that how do you add extra fonts. So right now,
if we go to our fonts, so for example, here is
a font, this is the only font that is inside our
pilot. So let me just close this, how do you add
other fonts inside this, so what you can do is
you can go to a website or something and download
fonts. And they will give you a font that is of
extension dot TTF. And you can just download this,
place it inside your project structure, and just
write the name of the font. So for example, what
you can do is you can go to this website known as
d a font. And this gives a lot of fonts for free.
So you can download just any any font that you
want. And we're going to give you a zip file, just
extract that zip file, and it's going to give you
a dot TTF file, then paste that TTF file inside
the Space Invader project folder, and just write
the name over here. And then you can use that
font inside your plugin. So this is pretty easy.
And this transfer the font size. So let me just
increase for sign to something crazy 70 maybe it's
not that crazy. But as you can see the score has
increased to 70 says, but let's keep it let's keep
it small 32 pixels. Alright guys. So that's pretty
much it. So let's just to recap a little bit,
first we create the score value, we added a font
object, then we created the x and y coordinates
of the font where we want it to appear. And
then inside a show score, we did two things,
we rendered the font and then we blurted it or
drew it on the screen, and render we applied or
gave it three values, the score the true and the
color of our text, so you can change it to green.
So let me just show it to you. Yes, RGB. So GB
should be 255. And then we can make both of these
values are zero red and blue. And this should make
it green. Let's play it. And as you can see, it's
green. But we want to invite color white, I think
looks good on any game. So let me just change it
to 255 again. Alright, let me just give a space
over here. And then we do it on the screen. And
then the last thing we did was before changing the
value of our scores, so after collision, we need
to make sure that the score value is increasing
by one after we hit the enemy by a bullet. And
the second thing is we call the show on the score
function that is pretty standard. Alright guys,
so in the next video, we are going to learn
how to end the game. So right now the game
is not ending is just keep on going even if the
enemy hit our spaceship. So one thing I noticed
is that the enemies are not moving very fast.
So we'll also increase the speed of the enemy
a little bit in the next video. And we'll make
these minor changes. So I'll see you over there.
Alright guys, welcome back. And hopefully
you're having a great day. And today we are
going to learn about how to add sounds and music
to our PI game. And currently there are no sounds
inside our game. So it looks pretty simple.
But what we are going to do is we are going
to add three types of sounds. The first sound
is the background sound that's going to play
continuously in the background. The second is
the shooting of the bullet sound. In this case,
I call it laser dot wave. And the third
one is explosion dot wave that is going
to be produced when our laser bullet hits our
enemy. And just to show you guys how it sounds,
I'm going to play this main dot Python file,
which I have already changed the code off so that
you guys can see what's happening inside again. So
I'm just gonna play it and you can see Alright, so
you must have seen there are three sounds first on
continuously goes in the background. Second is the
laser or the bullet sound. And the third is when
our bullet hits our enemy. Now how can you get all
these three files? Let me actually make sure that
the code is original and the last one that we have
used. And now how do you get these three dot WAV
files. So what I want you to guys to do is I want
you to go to github.com arthropod Space Invaders
by game and you will be able to get all the code
that I've written till now and along with it you
will be able to get the.pe files that I have been
talking about after downloading these three files
or maybe the whole code and you can download them
by clicking on this clone or download and done
download zip. Make sure you add the sound files
to your project by going to Space Invader and just
pasting them over there. Now let's get started
with adding background music into our game. So
first thing we need to do is import something
Known as a mixer from our pygame Library. And to
do that we just right from pi game, import mixer,
import this mixer. And what does this mixer This
is basically a class that helps us handle all
kinds of music inside our game, whether it can
be repeating our music, loading, music, anything
that want. So you have to look inside this class
whenever you want to do anything with sounds or
music. And then just below this background, we
are going to add a background sound. So let's
write our comments. so that you guys can know in
future what we are talking about. And then we're
just going to use the mixer library by writing
mixer dot music dot load pretty easy, because
we want to load the file and then we are going to
play the file. And inside this, we're just going
to write background dot WAV, which is the name of
our file, as you can see on the left hand side,
and then we're just gonna play this sound by
writing mixer dot music dot play pretty easy.
And now we want this file to play continuously.
Because right now, if you don't add anything
inside this dot play, this file is going to play
once and then just stop, but we want it to play
in a loop because this is a game and can go on for
long. We don't want it to play just once. And how
do you do that inside this mixer class, you just
add minus one and it's going to play on loop. So
now let's just test it out and see whether it's
working or not. As you can hear the background
music must be going on. But we haven't yet added
the sound to the experience town so that must not
be there. So that's why we are going to be working
on adding the bullets are now but one thing I want
you guys to notice is that currently we are using
mixer dot music because we want this file to be
played continuously in the background. So this
is kind of music. But as something is very short,
for example our bullet sound then we have to use
mixer dot sound. So we are going to come below
where we have a bullet shooting. So how are we
going to catch the moment when our bullet is being
released. So we are going to do that inside our
let's go to above let's go to this if bullet state
is ready. So over here we can release the sound
of our bullet going out from our spaceship. So
because over here we are getting the x coordinate
of the spaceship and then we are shooting the
bullet over here so we can somewhere over here at
our bullet Stan. And how do you do that is also
very easy. Just below this we are going to write
mixer dot sound. So in this case, it's not mixer
dot music, it's mixer adult sound. And we're
gonna first create a variable let's create a
variable and call it bullet underscore sound just
to make sure that we know where our sound is,
and makes a dot sound and inside this you have
to give the file of the sound so and that's in
our case is laser dot WAV. And then just like we
did in the music case, we are going to play it so
we're just gonna write bullets sound, not state
will it sound dot play, and we don't want it to
be played inside a loop. That's why we haven't
added minus one. So now our bullets is making
a sound now we just need to add a sound to our
collision. And where are we catching collision
let me just copy this first and we are going to
go below I just want you to guess first where we
are going because this is pretty obvious we are
going to this part where if collision we want a
sound p plate and that sound is off explosions.
So we're just going to copy and paste this over
here because most of the things are going to
be same instead of bullet we're going to write
explosion sound. And then I'm just going to copy
and paste this just below this play and instead of
laser dot wave we are going to go with explosion
dot wave. So that's this is pretty much it. Let's
actually play our game one more time and see if
everything is working properly. So let's play this
Alright guys, so everything is looking really
good. So are all of the three sounds are playing
obviously Feel free to walk around and play
around and add more sounds maybe remove and
add your own songs. That's going to be fun. In
the next video we are going to learn about how to
make sure that our game gets over when our enemy
hits our spaceship. So I'll see you over there.
In the last video, we learn how to add sounds
to our game and in this video we are going to
show the game over a screen. So I removed all of
the sounds for this video because it's going to
be difficult to explain what's going on if I add
the sound. So what we're going to do is when many
of these enemies come close to our spaceship
maybe over here, we're going to remove all of
these enemies or maybe just get them out of the
screen. And we are going to show a big test just
like we are shown over here the score zero we
are going to show a big text of game over over
here in the middle of the screen. And when is this
pixels gonna head without these enemies gonna come
close to the spaceship when they're gonna hit
the y axis of 440 pixel. So if you remember at
the top at zero pixel at the bottom is 600 pixel
and adjust at the starting of the spaceship it's
about 480 pixel, but just by experimenting, I
found out that 440 is perfect. So when I use
that 440 pixel As a limit, so when our enemies
come over here, we are going to show game over
for our player. And the final score is going to
be shown over here. So what we are going to do
is we are going to come to our enemies where we
are moving our enemies basically. So we'll come
down and come to enemy movement. So enemy
movement was over here. And then over here,
we are just going to add a text. So let's add
a text and just call it Game Over, because we
are going to be writing the game over code just
below this. And what do you want is when whenever
an enemy lets enemy right, and whenever enemy
Why have I so whenever one of the enemies and
doesn't need to be all of the enemies when one of
the enemies come to for 40 pixels. And actually,
just to test it out, I don't want the enemies to
come to the bottom. So I'm going to make it very,
very small, maybe 200 pixels. And just when we are
ending the game and we are finalizing the game,
I'm going to change it again to 440 pixels. So
whenever one of the enemies come to 200 pixels,
then what we want to do, we want to move all
the enemies, so we are on create another for
loop for j n. And then we just want to copy
all of these, because we want to move all
the enemies out of the screen, that's how I'm
going to create another for loop inside this
big for loop. And then under this and is going to
change the axis of enemy y j equals to 2000. And
this should make sure that these enemies go below
the screen to 2000 y pixel. And then after this,
I'm gonna just make sure that we display
the game over text. So how do you do that,
I'm just going to create a function. And this
function will be called underscore game over text.
And we are going to call this function and then we
are going to break out of this loop. So let's make
sure that we are not doing anything weird with the
brackets and over here we are just going to write
break. And this looks pretty good. So what we are
doing is whenever an enemy, it doesn't need to be
all the enemies when one of the enemies reaches
is greater than 200 pixels in this case, but it's
actually going to be 440. And then we are going to
collect all of the enemies inside this for loop.
And we want each of the enemies to be moved out of
the screen. And we are doing that by setting the
y axis to 2000. It is not going to be shown on the
screen. And then we're calling this game over text
function which is going to display the game over
text on the screen. And then we are breaking out
of this loop because we don't need this for i in
range loop anymore. So now let's create this game
over underscore test functions. So we are going to
go where we have added our score. So let's just go
over here. So you can see we have added our score
over here. So we are going to do doing basically
the same thing. And we are going to write game
over text over here. And then we're going to copy
the same thing that we have done over here. And
instead of font we are going to just write game,
or we can write or underscore font, and we want
the font to be bigger. So this is the size of the
font, we are going to make it 64 by 64 pixel The
size is bigger. And then we are going to create
our function. So just below this show underscore
function, we are going to create our game over
next function. And we are going to do the same
thing that we did previously with our show under
score function. And then over here, let's just
copy and paste this line. So we are going to copy
this paste over here. And then instead of score,
let's just call it over underscore text. And then
we don't need all of this stuff, we just need to
be displayed game. And let's make it in capitals,
just to make sure it looks good. Game over. So
this is looking good, then we just need to blurt
it all drawn on the screen, we're gonna copy and
paste this over here, let's just press enter and
paste this over here. And then instead of score,
we are going to write over underscore text. And
we are not because we are not going to use the
x and y values, we can use it but because our
game worst takes is going to be displayed at one
place. So I'm going to remove this and instead
of that, I'm just gonna write 202 50 pixels.
And this 200 comma 250 pixel is basically the
middle of the screen, you can try out different
values and see what works for you. But basically,
I've divided the both of these values by two and
made it a little bit less both the x and y axis.
And that's how I got to the center obviously, you
to change the values a little bit so that it looks
good. Anyway, so this is looking pretty good right
now let's run our main.py file and see if it's
working. And you have to remember that we have
made it 200 pixels. And you can see that again,
what else is being displayed, but it's not in the
middle and it's not big. So why is that happening.
And this is because we have used the same font
over here that we have created previously,
this font, we need to change this. And because
we have created a new font that is known as
the Oh font. So we're just going to copy this
and paste this instead of font don't render we
are going to paste over underscore font, because
this is our new font. And this font for used for
a score. That's why it's so small. let's reload
it and hopefully this time it will work. So let's
wait for it to come to 200 y axis and after that
is going to show the game or screen so now you
can't hit any of the enemies so the score is going
to remain constant. So let me just show it to you
again. Let me just hit A couple of enemies. And
now we have hit our enemies. So let's wait for our
200 pixel to get over. And it's going to happen
anytime soon. All right, it's your end game over.
And now because you can't hit any more enemies,
your score is going to remain constant. Obviously,
you can add more buttons like play again and do
stuff like that. But by now you already know how
to do it. So I'm not going to go into it again.
So now finally, let's change is now that we know
that our code is working instead of 200. Let's
change it to 440 pixels. And make sure you add the
sounds again and make it a complete game. So guys,
this is pretty much it. For this video series, we
created our space invader games from scratch. And
if you were a beginner who didn't know anything
about pi game or creating games, now you have
a basic understanding of how a game is created.
It has been wonderful hanging out with you guys.
So thank you for watching and I'll see you around